[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
day two of the us chess championship
being played as both a rapid and
online for the very first time america's
leading players were back in action and
looking to blow their main rivals off
the chessboard
wesley seoul won two incredible games to
make it five in a row to start the event
but ray robson and jeffrey jean won two
games as well
and are snapping at wesley's heels it's
the penultimate day with three
critical rounds on the line day three of
exciting action
coming up next
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020
us chess championship as
october near is its finale i am with the
other saramon and maurice ashley to call
day three of the u.s championship hello
jennifer hello maurice hello everyone
thank you for joining us
and sharing your day yesterday
i found to be enthralling i mean
i was riveted and the action just kept
coming coming and that final matchup
between ray robson and sam savion
clutching my heart i wasn't sure what
was going on
i am looking forward to more action more
of the same
maurice i'm sure you are as well
well the dodgers won the world series
yesterday
and the players in this tournament have
brought out the big bats
they're trying to bash bash each other
over the head
and we're seeing just some incredible
games
up and down bring out the defibrillator
because
there are heart palpitations in every
single round
this is exciting stuff we love it and we
expect to see more of the same today
jennifer tell us about the standings
well they are remarkable standings
yasser wesley so
started with a perfect 5-0 finally
nicked for just half a point
goes in to day three with five and a
half out of six you would think that
would be like a full point lead or more
but no jeffree zhang and ray robson
right on his heels
with five out of six but look at the
distance between
this formidable trio and the rest of the
field
look it's just too big one of these top
three are going to win the event
quite remarkable hikaru nakamura and
even score essentially out of things
and tell us about the format well we've
got
a 12 player round robin and that means
we have 11 rounds they're playing for
fifty thousand dollars time control game
25 with a five second increment so it
gets very heated towards the end
but sometime to dig into the openings
and strategies in the beginning of the
game
we will have a tie break if needed for
first place
and the schedule for those of you who
are just joining us well we're nearing
the close
we've got three rounds today and then
two tomorrow
plus playoff if we need it
very nice and now we have more wreaths
to talk to us a little
bit about the road ahead for our three
contenders here for the crowd
indeed it's the three musketeers folks
there's nobody else to look at the odds
are
one of these three players will win it
and they have just been performing
superlatively
let's break down how they have done as
you see there
five and a half for wesley five for
jeffrey and ray
that that triplet they've got three
scores there
that probably adds up to about the next
six combined it's
unbelievable how well they're doing and
let's
dig a little bit deeper as we go to
these illustrious players
first of all one of the
younger players but actually he's been
around so long i think this is his 14th
straight championship so hard to call
him a youngin anymore
but ray robson with a great performance
so far
two wins on each day although
yesterday's round six was insane
could have lost that game if salmon
found that spectacular move
nevertheless he won the game and now
stands at five points tied for second
he's got a tough road ahead as you're
gonna see the leaders playing
each other you see there that round
eight he has against jeffrey today in
round nine
against nakamura as well challenging
pairing to be sure
and it's round ten that we're going to
have our eye on because
it's wesley so that he has to play now
check out the next youngster he turns 20
in a couple of days but still a teenager
will he be one of the only teenagers to
ever
win this event jeffrey zhang it's a
mirror image folks
same for same day same different day
same performance two wins and a draw
and he is looking to rise to the top
but he has a very difficult day
today look at those three players all
three have played in the olympiad
we're talking about part of the olympic
team that jeffrey will have to go up
against in round seven
eight and nine this is where the biggest
challenge is going to be
if he can get through this well then he
probably will be optimistic
with his last two rounds and finally
the leader standing above everyone else
and what can you say about wesley so
look at those numbers
we got a lot of ones man five wins in a
row
no one had done that in an invitational
in the u.s championship
since bobby fischer in 1963
64 campaign incredible performance
indeed but he said
himself lid wesley what the heck i'm at
five and a half and there's somebody
right behind me
in fact two players right behind yes
indeed and guess what folks
those two players he has yet to play as
we look at the rest of his lineup
he will have the very difficult sam
sevillan el shawn
muradiabadi is playing well just only
one loss so far
in the event and then he will have to
play jeffrey
and ray and close it out with a karu
this will not be easy at all who knows
what's going to happen
and if the first two days are any
indication guys
this is going to be a thrilling finish
all the way to the end
thank you maurice very challenging
indeed and jen
set the table for us what can we expect
for round seven pairings
well we've got some big pairings this
round as our top three players all with
the white
pieces and it's jeffrey zhang against
hikaru nakamura
big battle there while ray robson plays
against
el shawn moradi abadi coming off his
first loss
of the event and wesley so over sam
sevilla and that'll be the game that we
start with
as we see if wesley can just run away
with this thing
well and finally jen break down
the prize fund you mentioned earlier 150
000
yes 150 thousand dollars 40k for first
something for everyone but more than
anything
it's that title that is for life
very generous price fun thank you to the
same field and to the st
louis chess club for all your generosity
very very nice prize fund
like you said something for everyone now
i gotta tell you yesterday i'm still
like i was shattered because i
looked over some of those games and
maybe it's a time control that is
uh creating these lopsided scores but
whatever it is
it sure is exciting to behold maurice
sure is you know the thing is if you if
you think about it we've had this same
time control in the last four
events so it's something special about
this tournament
right now that's creating this
ridiculous score
can you imagine jeffrey zhang and ray
robson are two points ahead
of ikaro nakamura the last winner and
sam
shanklin the winner before that there
are two full points ahead
and wesley is two and a half points
ahead but we're
just seeing three players with
extraordinary performances that's what
we're seeing
and we just hope to see more of the same
as they're going to do battle against
each other in the day
a couple of days to come and even today
and that means that mathematically at
some point it's
going to become almost impossible for
anyone else to win because they're
playing
each other so they're getting points
against each other exactly
or lose not yet but i would say if
anybody else were going to win they'd
have to win
five games in a row which isn't
impossible and wesley started with 5-0
but they would have to do that and the
top players would have to
do not that well um by the way guys
here's a proposition for you we know
you already picked wesley so but suppose
we all had to pick now
and we had a choice you could get either
wesley or you could get ray
and jeffrey who would you pick
would you go with a half point and you
know the
the elite player or would you go with
the two younger guys
in fantastic form well ray robson and
wesley are a similar age but
um you know what i'm saying great
proposition bet because
i think of wesley as a great
front-runner but he's going to be
facing both of uh jeffrey and ray
uh in the tournament to come and if he
were to get upset
so you would give me the field meaning
ray and
jeffrey and you would take
wesley with the half a point uh
i think i'd go with wesley but it's a
really good proposition bet
it's a postponed it's a close it is and
i would go with the half point of course
i think i'm not even sure if it weren't
wesley if he were one of the others if i
wouldn't go with the half point because
it's
such a big half point but with wesley
with the rating difference as well
yeah yeah i know it wasn't and the
chance
and the chance to win in the playoff i
think that's the other trouble like
wesley's gonna be a big favorite if he
faces either one in the playoffs
especially ray i think
by the way ray is one year younger than
wesley so 26 year old ray
um just turned 26 actually a couple days
ago happy birthday
well this is a happy birthday tournament
for him as we dig into the games wesley
sow
versus sam sethion we've got open ray
and open rui and uh the both players now
wesley
plays the i'm sorry i'm trying to
interrupt you yes i'm sorry to interrupt
you
i just something really weird just
happened just a quick deja vu
this open rui i was reading the book the
queen's gambit
and before i watch the series so don't
tell me anything about it those of you
who've watched
but this the open rui features exactly i
was
in a scene in the middle of the book
where i just about where i am and i was
reading yesterday about
this variation of the the real lopez
and i'm just i'm like what this is
certain deja vu i guess the odds are
you know it couldn't happen any day it's
really oppressed but it's so weird that
we're talking about the act the player
beth harmon
and it was an open rui and she lost
badly to the then world champion borghof
et cetera et cetera which is
a weird deja vu moment for me sorry
continue not at all it's fantastic uh
yeah just as you were saying jen and
open rui the players have blitzed
right through this opening theory
i wanted to say that wesley
has the open rui in his repertoire as
black
he's played it consistently throughout
his career
and i always felt a little bit
nervous about entering the same
territory
that my opponent you know is a
specialist in
sam didn't back down he went right for
this
variation and the move and knight
d4 to e2 uh
in the past captures and f3
has been played but overall black's
results have been
pretty fine as he's held his own
after 92 rook d8 i'm not so familiar
with knight f4
as i am with the idea of a2 a4
white tries to open up the a file for
his rook without moving the rook
the bishop it's not clear where the
bishop wants to go so if you don't have
to develop the bishop if you can go a4
a b and rook a6 you're in business but
knight f4 and
look how fast they have been blitzing
knight f4 d4 takes on d4
okay everybody's expecting
c takes no no no that would allow knight
takes e6
followed by bishop b3 so sam says well
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
insert the move bishop c4
an intermezzo once you move your rook
then i'll capture the pawn
and i'll be ready to play the move d3
not so fast
you want my rook you can have it says
wesley
please take my rook leave me with these
two connected past pawns
in the center of the board and sam said
no can do
must eliminate that and again
i i suspect because they've been playing
so fast
i suspect the players are in their prep
but boy this looks like
good stuff to me guys this is really an
amazing uh game thus far
18 moves whipping with all these
wild complications and wesley continuing
now with the movie f3 after the first
pregnant pause of the game and he's
still looking
he's trying to remember everything about
the position and sam there
very casually eyeing this move as he's
played
f3 a typical move in the open route when
the knight
gets to f3 i got to tell you i'm seeing
deja vu
everywhere as knight g5 has occurred
because
another scene if you look at the game
with alejandro
and his own slough
student or former slew student daria
spirits
they're playing in this opening and if
you look at move three
alejandro played this move d3
and said if you want to exchange queens
go right ahead you could take on e4 and
take and
queen takes and i'm going to tell you
again the same scene
it's not the exact same position but the
same question was asked for the
protagonist beth harmon in the book
in the book queens gambit i don't know
if it shows up in the netflix series
that's now out and by the way i hear
that it's the number one
netflix series in america which is
extraordinary for a chess
a a show with with chess as its central
theme
to be the number one viewed series
in on netflix in the u.s very bendable
very bingeable and they they get a lot
of the openings right but
there are different openings in the book
you know it's been a while since i read
the book i read it as a little kid
and i just reordered it i heard it's
also sold out
on amazon
[Music]
hello
uh apologies uh dear viewers for that
little break
but uh i hope we are back i was just
looking at some games during that inter
meso
unscheduled as it was and i tell you i'm
i'm looking across the board and i'm
seeing some really exciting games
including uh the game of geoffrey zhang
hikaru
nakamura as well as ray robson and
elshon
um good stuff so far it looks like
everybody came prepared to play some
hard chess
sharp positions indeed and that's what
you want
when you are absolutely in the mix
in such a critical round this game with
jeffrey and hikaru is quite interesting
as sharp
as it is i mean look at the pawn
structure that hikaru has
not very cohesive but it's not that easy
to place
jeffrey's pieces particularly his
knights
on key aggressive squares in order to
pressure the position so jeffrey has
gone for the opening
of the queen side with the move c3
exactly hoping to utilize
uh a c file with rook c1
yes so rooksy won and
it looks to me that yeah it did it came
from
a perk defense and i was gonna say that
hikaru
uh he's such an elusive player
very very hard to pin him down but when
he feels his backs to the wall and he
has to do
some kind of a rampage uh
more often than not he'll pick a perk to
mix it up
yeah yeah perk i mean i think it's a
very dangerous choice
but yes it's not it's not the bomb cloud
no thank goodness for that you won't see
that in rapid games
that's blitz only right and by the way
for jeffrey that's ideal right
because uh from jeffrey's point of view
he's in an extraordinary situation you
know i mean he can
he can see there's a potential gold
medal
uh on the line here and he wants
hikaru to take risk he doesn't want to
see
hikaru play as if ah the tournament's
over it doesn't have any
more practice uh for for for me i'll
just make some draws and i'll shut it
down with berlin's
no no no he's very happy that
hikaru has mixed it up with this very
aggressive defensive line the perk
defense
and now the knight i like what you were
saying there maurice
the move c3 i really wanted to see
um jeffrey actually capture
on br b4 and bring the knight more
towards the
queen side on g3
i'm not a big fan i don't think that the
knight does very well
for itself on g3 of course it defends
the pawn on e4 that's very important
pawn
but i see it much more defensively
minded than offensively geared
and by the way we have some big news
wesley so has already
drawn his game against sam seven draw
with the white pieces one thing i'll
i'll say is what that signifies to me
guys is that
this isn't close to a must-win situation
for jeffrey zhang like if he were to
draw this game against ikaru
i think he's going to get more
opportunities to equal wesley's score as
wesley's approach
seems to be sedate after running up
5-0 yeah a massive score to start for
sure
but that kind of opened you know like
you like that
don't you you maurice uh that door kind
of gets
wedged open a little bit for ray robson
and
for uh jeffrey um not sure
but i say could i please say that
frankly
this is a really critical decision but
we've seen it by wesley before
wesley tens from from the years we've
watched him
wesley tends to be a bit more
conservative
when he gets a lead he he'll say look
you've got to catch me i don't have to
catch you and if i can just
stay solid even with the white pieces i
mean he had the white pieces in
a very sharp position he said if i can
just say solid i'll pick my spots
and i'll challenge those guys to see if
they can stay consistent because
he's figuring they have to win to catch
him
or if he draws they have to win to catch
him and how many
risks are they willing to take they're
playing in
what would be their first big spot in
the championship to play for
victory but i just find that
i guess my heart is not in this kind of
way of approaching things i can see
people like gary kasparov and magnus
carlson saying
when i'm on a rampage no one in front of
me
should think they're getting any easy
draws i'm going to kill
everybody i'm in top form and i'm just
going all out to destroy you so whenever
we see
wesley do this it's been great for him
before
but sometimes it it does bite him and
so i'm a little concerned that he's
taking his foot off the gas this early
and kind of
estimating that his chances are better
if he just draws
and play conservatively the rest of the
way it has brought him a u.s
championship in the past but i hear loud
and clear
when you're on a rampage as is wesley so
you really want to see wesley
push his luck and see what he can do in
this position he decided to play rook d
juan trade rooks here you can understand
why i would be
you know playing for the move a4 to take
bring the rook in but after the trade
this very important move g7 g6 by sam
and then after rook d7 the quick rook
trade bishops of opposite color
draw let's move on wesley uh defending
his pole position
and how is jeffrey doing not much of a
difference since we left let's just jump
in
on that game of ray robson because this
is one of those games one of those
french defense
situations where nothing nothing
nothing has been traded but in my view
all of the advantages lie with the white
pieces why because even if you get
in this move b4 you know you're freeing
break if you will
as white and first of all there is a
problem with the a file i understand but
even if you get in the
move b4 you only drive the knight to a
better square
in the meanwhile it's all about the
break for white
g4 f5 and sometimes you play f5 first
followed by g4 other times you play g4
and f5
when white gets in his break it's much
much much more meaningful than when
black does so for the moment this looks
like
you know door opening for ray robson
as he's sitting there going yeah i can
play g4 i can play
f5 i can see my way uh to a very serious
attack against black's king you know i'm
having a bit of deja vu here yes is
yesterday
i said that in the position he played
against savion
no matter what there was going to be a
time scramble because the position was
so rich and dynamic
with so few trades and it just didn't
seem like a position
that you know you'd be able to solve and
rapid and inevitably be
reviewed something crazy and indeed
that's exactly what happened it was so
nutty
ray did get the best of him um but i'm
kind of like
seeing that again that ray likes to kind
of elongate the games if you will
so there's a lot of games that kind of
erupt
right when there's time pressure and
that benefits him
as long as his opponent is also in time
pressure because
he's just really good at attacking and
really good
at um playing better than his opponent
when they're both down to seconds on the
claw
yeah because we focus so much
on our preparation on our technique
on our understanding we forget things
like
nerves nerves are very very important
when you're playing a fast time control
yeah you have all of that knowledge you
know how to win with a rook and bishop
versus a rook or to draw
but when you've got seconds on your
clock that's when nerves can take over
and you can do some terribly bad things
you've got certain players and i would
include for example hikaru nakamura in
there
who have great nerves they really really
do
play well under pressure ray robson
who's really used to the pressure
the time trouble i mean he plays really
good
under pressure we'll see uh if he can
keep it up
for this game yes that's such a
fantastic point you made
i mean it is such a fantastic point when
in competition
there is something else that enters your
body
and that is what you're talking about
the nervous tension
we as commentators the three of us we
get to sit it back
relax casually no no
nervous tension at all in our bodies
that we were so used to
as practicing players and we can see the
move and said
what how did you miss that move because
that that nervous tension is not
impeding us in
any way whatsoever we can just casually
see what should be the right move like
alejandro missing that double sacrifice
yesterday that would have made it
one de yeah it's easy to see when you're
on the side and you're just cast
oh what's the answer here oh yeah just
hit him in the face of course if
alejandro was sitting with us he'd say
oh dog yeah but when you're sitting
in the hot seat it's a whole different
feeling and that is part of
competitive chess that's part of what
you have to suffer with and not only
that you got money on the line you got a
title on the line
everything to play for that's what it's
all about i love your point
the nerves that stop professionals from
thinking
as efficiently as they would normally
by the way we've got to look at the game
with jeffree zhang and karan nakamura
because they're being
a big development where it looks like
jeffrey's trying to exploit
something that just happened on the
board i love seeing moves like this
just go back one move when the rook was
on
f8 and jeffrey just played rook c1
and rook fc8 looks innocuous
which rook do you move and you move this
rook over to the square you think
no big deal what could be wrong with
this move and jeffrey said i'm going to
show you
capture on b4 capture back and then
bishop to c4 intact and you go
what what wait a minute my rook was
supposed to stay
guarding the f7 pawn a small weakness
spotted
quickly by the youngster that shows
fantastic form guys
that's the kind of stuff you want to see
come out of a player and that's amazing
form that he noted that
and ikaru now going wait wait wait i
didn't expect
this sacrifice and the threat of knight
g5 now
is real actually in the position it will
chase your rook back
to f8 something you just don't want to
do and here you see nakabora
looking at it saying oh boy i got to be
careful
no question about it uh nicely spotted
by
by jeffrey to be sure but it really does
beg the question
what was this rook doing on a8 that was
so
pertinent why not use it
just as white played his rook on a1 to
the c5 why not play your rook on
a8 and that little nuance right there
allowed this move bishop c4 if the if
the rook had been on f8
then i think the e4 pawn might have been
hanging but now you're sitting there
looking at knight g5
and you can't stop knight g5 with the
desired h6
oops there's already a battery on uh the
diagonal so uh knight g5 i think you
said
this move is going to chase the rook
back to f8 uh
that could be problematic though rook
might land on c7
uh so let's just see a move like knight
um c5 for a moment to knight e6
or yeah i'm trying both right because
i'm expecting knight g5 in any case
right
but how would this oh excuse me i wasn't
going to go knight g5 i was going to go
takes
i i apologize uh rook takes knight g5
and yeah and now if you play try to get
some comp with
rook c4 and h6 i don't even win your i
don't even win your e-pawn at the end of
the day because the rook protects it
exactly that's that's not enough
not even close but is this but will the
combination
work after rook f8 because i i had
planned
yeah that's why i thought i thought
taking on f7 here would be winning but
you're saying it's knight f7 there's
rook c4
so you take that instead right exactly
and then if i do
this uh i'm not sure
am i breaking in help me uh uh
rook d7 check isn't a big threat again
the knight on g3
it's kind of anemic uh
maybe you started we were like g5 and
then like
because if you start with knight g5 the
cool thing is if you play rook f8 now
i just have bishop c5 and i win your
queen
yeah here here's the issue though jen
knight g5
knight takes right yeah so we take
okay if we take this complicated yeah
and now
you play queen f7 i see that's what
you're trying bingo yeah
yes exactly so uh my
uh black's queen is hanging white's
queen is hanging
um it's still not the end of the story
right because there's takes takes
i think stakes
and this is
weird slightly better for white because
of those pawns on a5 and b4
yeah this guy could be vulnerable right
oops
weird weird weird stuff but okay that's
what the players are calculating again
for those who are joining his light
our front runner wesley so has made a
very early draw with sam seven
sam so he's currently a point clear of
the field that
both uh jeffrey and rey could tie
wesley were they to win their games and
we were just looking at a
possible variation for jeffrey turning
our attention
to the game by the way i'm sorry i just
wanted to make a note
because you've at such a great point
about bringing the
other rook to c8 yeah and
then i noted that bishop c4
it not only attacks the f7 point but it
also unleashes an attack on the d7
knight
right right so it's it's a double it's a
double point
this bishop on c4 that when the anybody
no one can take on e4
because the knight is actually hanging
so you you're not even tactically
defending the pawn right with this
f7 tactic it's also the knight on d7
so it's not clear that the other root to
ca
fix this issue either
well if we think maurice i hear you loud
and clear if we
think that um knight c5
is is almost a forced move here right if
we think that knight c5 is almost a four
force move then with the rook on
f8 we wouldn't have to bother
trying to calculate ramifications of
knight right exactly here
oh my god by the way oh my gosh guys ray
robson game i'm getting you an alert
from verrusa
kobien a winning tactic alert and it's
it's a beauty
um right now it's white's move and
varsity don't say it don't say it yeah
yeah has already found it oh yeah you
found it what
i didn't even get a chance to look at
the board sorry maurice
is too sharp i didn't expect it i did i
just turned to the position and the
guy's sacking pieces already
he's not a position he's a positional
guy but right now
he's in a tactical mood as he saw this
uh bishops before unleashing the power
of the pawn on
d4 to d5 and then i guess it's not
it's it's more like a mini tactic you
just win upon right
right uh for me i thought that this was
actually a
very big move by uh ray robson
i really thought that you know ray would
you know start with g4
and just go for this whole f5 uh
in principle it's dangerous to play in
your opponent's theater
what i don't understand i understand you
guys are we went too fast past the
tactic
i'll bring it back up in a second
because i'm still calculating i'm trying
for the win still
okay uh it's very dangerous to play in
your opponent's theater we got to assume
that
you know the queen side is black's
territory leave that territory
alone let's play in our sandbox our
sandbox is the king side let's go g4 and
f5
in principle this move is rather
uh sharp in my view because i think it's
a pawn sacrifice
after you play a4b for knight b5 uh
the most um challenging
if you're black is to play the move
bishop a6 first of all your bishop on
c8's
lousy it's terrible let's get rid of it
let's trade it for a night
you let me take this night yeah yeah i'm
very excited
of course ray is planning on
playing knight d6 check and this is
doubtlessly what he calculated
why isn't he playing bishop c4 anyway
which he has done now in the game
yes your line seems to seems to also beg
the move bishop takes on c4 and d5
this this is nothing or or what i know
uh and by i mean this looks you're
winning the piece back
five in this position knight d6 check
take the knight
or knight d6 check take the bishop then
take the knight right
right i mean that's that's this line by
the way this is where he's headed and
that's why i'm asking
that's what happened yeah there's no
there's no immediate winning of a pawn
here
knight takes on c5 and the attack
continues of course there's going to be
a knight f7
and it's going wild but it's not just a
simple one two three punch
you went upon and looked at el shawn
he's saying
prove your attack i'm taking the piece
i'm up a piece and this is what
ray had to calculate as the bishop is
ready to capture on e6 as well
it's yeah it's only the beginning yeah
just catch up with the players quickly
i don't like this move of elshon knight
a7 i think i should just
leave it there and say that uh
bishop a6 was more challenging el shawn
played knight a7
and this led to the p sacrifice that we
have in the game
which is bishop takes c4 now d takes c4
what else
if you let white just retreat as bishop
he'll be a pawn up so he took and now d5
and this was the tactic that i saw as
well
the bishop on e3's unleashed now what
maurice is saying is
wait a minute it is a p sacrifice uh
bishop c5 bishop takes c5 knight takes
e5
all on the board knight shack to the
king king went to f8 and here
were you mentioning something going
after the f7 pawn maurice well
um right ray went fast
like ignored that completely and said no
i'm just gonna take a second pawn
and challenge your queen to keep an eye
on your knight
and it's going to be a third pawn as d6
quickly played
queen c6 and now yes you gotta like this
one more may i have another
yeah the three pawns uh
yeah i look i'm a pawn grabber you all
know that but
here uh sorry to be a party pooper
like yeah i like that pawn very much but
maurice
don't we like the pawn that's protecting
the guy's king
even more i totally loved that pawn
absolutely that's where i thought the
attack was going and that queen will
stream into the dark squares as well
i can't say that this is terrible as
black's pieces
look terrible but i mean black's pieces
right now are completely scattered
knight on c5 is probably gonna hang the
queen
is running all over the place and every
other black piece is on the back row
this must be winning for white must
but the other line looks so juicy as
well
that's why when you started with the
sacrifice i was like whoa whoa this is
getting crazy actually
and it's an unclear sacrifice not one of
those that just like i pick a pawn off
what a crazy line ray's going into but i
think he's just winning
yeah i mean this looks just dominant
where you're down a piece but look at
that
pawn trio you have three pawns and then
look at the pawns they are oh they're
just so pretty
um they're they're pretty yeah for stuff
like knight b5
here threatening knight c7 if you take
twice oh i guess you could
take and then take on a juan okay and
then unfortunately
if i could escape with my king i'd be
very very happy
to trade off two rooks for a queen but
i wouldn't be super super enthusiastic
about white's position
uh materially i would say that white's
down even though he's got three pawns
for a piece
you know that's what we do we say three
pawns equals a knight
but it depends on what phase of the game
you're in in the end game phase
yeah the three pawns might even be worth
more than the knight in a middle game
with a lot of pieces on the board
not so sure that black isn't materially
ahead
put the bishop on d5 put the king on g7
and you know these three pawns look
really good but
unless they're attacking and moving
forwards
don't think of them as that great uh how
are you going to stop
how are you going to get
because uh if i play like if i start
sticking my queen on the dark squares
um this is going to be a bit annoying
right because it kind of reminds me of
the game yesterday where it's
hard to get any pieces to defend the
black king right
i know i i remember get was it wesley so
versus
yeah that yeah was you know even more
clear-cut
but that was very clear-cut yeah a guy
there's not a piece here that can come
to defense really
not really i just want to clean up this
variation sure sure i just mentioned
you said knight b5 was a move so yeah in
95
now is what was 64. what was wrong with
knight b5
now yeah we were we were i was i was
saying
if knight b5 pawn b5 queen no but 95
queen c5 uh how do you play aha so queen
c5 is probably a better move and then
if queen seven have nine beasts
i have knight um you have d7 you have b7
no no no no but
but i do have knight b6 with all the
threats still
so queen a7 knight b6 huh and now you're
defending d7
now this must be seven and b5 that this
must be winning
maybe 94 is uh an issue
uh but how is this an issue with mike
or my queen leaves and you play knight
b5 queen e4
and okay so if the queen leaves knight
b5
queen tempo on my queen with bishop b7
that should save you well i'm not sure
like take you take i can take on b7 even
right no no but then you have oh the end
game looks good for me too i'm not sure
if it's
actually winning but it looks it looks
queen a7 check trade queens and this
position after
b6 should be great maybe
i mean it looks fantastic but i want the
a
but you're going to play king g7 i must
be winning no
yes ray
uh paused i want to put it that way ray
paused before
he played b3 i'm sure knight b5
was on his agenda way back when um
something dissuaded him i'm not sure
what it is maybe queen c6
is that looks a little bit weird
it really does it was really weird he
did play
b3 and the game flared anew after b3
oops excuse me that was my move let me
just re refresh my board i apologize
uh knight d4 b3
bishop b7 that's what i was saying if
black could you know give him give black
two three moves give black the world
suddenly you know a peace could land
here a piece could land here
good things might happen for black's
position but we need more
then yeah exactly gotta keep on the pace
let's go with uh the attacking
and now a few players i like this yeah
and that's the thing i mean kg7 you just
get hit right back
you could play h6 but then you're not
even trying to get
your king to safety because king g7 is
still going to get hit by queen essex
so that's why by the way i'm just not
participating
and sacrifices on f5 are coming
inexorably well let me offer an obvious
move
uh the knight on a7 to my mind is really
pathetic
let me just stop queen e7
yes you can put your queen on f6 uh
but the idea is obviously please
rescue me capture good luck and
let me let me threaten mate and juan
that's all i ask
you're not getting that favor no way in
the world no uh
where do we go if we play f5 now you
have
when you have you don't you might start
like do you have knight takes d4
or is that going to be too i'm going to
close okay
it's like i close my eyes i play night
takes
i play knight takes and uh i i think i'm
getting there
back up is the question and now night at
five
yeah i think i'm gonna get killed i
think i'm gonna get killed
95 rook takes f5 in a blink of an eye
and now queen e7 and this attack is
yeah over fico g pawn will end on g7
at the end you have to play king g7 king
h6
actually the queen of six purses is
better to get a tempo
queen of six check first instead of
queen of seven
ah sorry gains the whole tempo and and
now you have to
die now you get king a6 and g7
or takes
i'm going to be down i'm going to be
down in the world
so rey vicious attack
vicious attack after this move queen h4
i played knight c6
maybe okay again i just go ahead and
kill me guys
let me put my [ __ ] okay your bishop is
your bishop is a good one that's
that's oh guardians remember i tried to
do this i tried to do this for
arena crush she was i see six on the
board
yeah and i tried to put her bishop on d5
against
you guys said knight d6 check
and knight f7 and it was a a
a brilliant combination for carissa uh
here
the move bishop d5 makes a lot more
sense just wait but queenie suddenly
check queen e7 king
queen f6 and what happened to her f5
idea
and by the way raiden played nazis
i'm sorry el shawn knights yeah now he
did play knight cheese oops sorry
yes uh maurice go ahead kill me bishop
no i wanted i wanted two moves in a row
and you didn't give it to me
i wanted to play i want to play d7 and
queen of six
together oh yeah and then yeah and then
you and then i can queen and i can
right like i just use material but i
can't get queen f6
and d7 or d7 and queen f6 because
your your rook is now in the way in the
94 and all
this this knight d6 that i'm and i'm
cooking
96 here no 1960 might just take me and
argue otherwise no well no then you get
your queen f6 then you get what you
wanted
if i could oh right right exactly so now
can i play f5 here
oh oh i'm just i'm crying swinging for
the fences
but maybe you could just take twice
maybe you're not losing is it possible i
can't believe it
that well the queen the queen shows up i
mentioned
it i know it's weird maybe you play rook
takes you ask do you play rook takes to
keep the queen out
wow this is an
insane position but maybe you hide and
do i meet you
because i can't play knight takes e4
because your queen is helping
yep wow uh a crazy crazy variation and
maybe bishop d5
was made was possible but knight c6 was
also
choice the idea from his point of view
is he wanted to chase the knight away to
resurrect his queen and ray said no
no no no no no
not trading any pieces and by the way
your queen
uh is really gummied up i mean
it just doesn't have well is knights
does knight c3 threaten the queen
actually
no i have c7 thank goodness uh
for el shawn that he has to move queen
c7
by the way i think that might change
your tune on the proposition
as ray's position is awesome and
jeffrey's position also looks i mean not
as
not as dazzling um in that queen search
rated but just look at the difference
between the quality of all the pieces
here
and in fact jeffrey intentionally traded
queens i'm having
total control over that important d6
square
and if you um continue on
uh we just have the situation where
every single one of white's pieces
is more active than blacks i mean you're
not happy with any of these guys
knight g5 threatening why not knight
earlier
bishop f7 rook f7 knight f7 king f7
and um it looks amazing what do you do
what is the defense here
you have to i guess you have to to
bolster more pieces in that square with
rookie 7 or 96.
i'm not happy about rookie 7. i i mean
96 i apologize uh 96 you
you just take remember unfortunately g5
on the board
on on e3 protects the rook on c1 meaning
that in this exact position
there's no pin on the c file uh
very important uh consideration now
after rookie seven
what was the kill i didn't see it i
don't know i don't see it i don't think
there's a kill i'm just saying that
right here white's
white's pieces all look so fantastic but
maybe bishop c5
um the problem is you can take and then
after
bishop f7 rook f7 roxy are you in time
to well i don't see what you're doing
yeah and now
two minor pieces
for two bishops and two pawns for a rook
that's not bad that a pawn might
just no but you know what h6 here
eight six might be a small
rook a7 oh yeah actually no
that's a good move yeah that's not
that's a good time well
timed actually so then it could be a lot
of other moves what about the sedate
rook b5 just trying to i love
the sedate i love the sedate move rook
b5
trying to pick up the pawn i i hesitated
might happen to basics yeah
yes that was the it's then i'd have to
go rook c5
and we'd go into something similar but
but now you let me trade
a bunch of pieces maybe well that i
thought that bishop on c4 was
really your best minor piece
and so somehow trading off the bishop on
b7
bishop on c4 might be a good deal in any
case hikaru
big time pressure oh and by the way var
gives a gorgeous line he says after
knight g5
if bishop c8 so basically protecting the
pawn with a
a simple move just by fixing the bishop
on b7
um now white has a bomb move
i don't know if i should let you guys
see it i should give you a hint yes
there it is
there it is guys can not help himself
it's incredible
such a party pooper he's the one in the
class
i got the people in the class doesn't
even raise his hand
you know i'm not going to raise my hand
the teacher says so what the answer to
yeah is it's excellent plus three and
the rest of the class is like what the
heck
how did we get a chance to look in
today's parlance
he uses the everyone zoom chat instead
of the private zoom chat
you tell the kids the private chat meet
not even bishop you know just give you
the answer right away
bishop a8 looks terrible and
wow quickly decided on with rook a6
yes he just moved over
oh my god that's incredible this is
he's just going to win the pawn guys and
then win the other pawn
this is this is going to be crushing for
jeffrey is
have we ever seen nakamura lose two
lower
rate of players in a row i mean not that
jeffrey's that much lower rated than him
um but in rapid he is right
he's getting tied up with knots all of
whites the only bad piece white has is
this knight on g3
and it might argue you know what i'm
just guarding on e4
so i i got a johnny i got a good job
i i wanted to share a friend of mine
herman van riemsdyk
international master from sao paulo
brazil came to seattle
and stayed with us and uh he wanted to
give this lecture
on king upon endgames with um
what is it corresponding squares so i
was giving this brilliant lecture
and everybody in the class was
mesmerizing a really really
wonderful lecture and he asked the class
so now what do you think and i raise my
hand and i go
i got the answer
herman was like give the others a chance
now
go outside play ball with somebody
uh by the way after rook a6 came
bishop b7 he karu is flailing
he is not a karo that we know because
uh everything is now winning for white i
mean rook a7
and you're renewing all of those
previous threats that you had when your
rook was on b6
look at his face and guys if wesley's
watching this round
he might start to regret taking an early
draw since both of his front runners
might catch up for them he should
absolutely
absolutely is a bigger score that's
going to win this tournament big scores
to win this tournament indeed
by the way he has just a note for people
watching um unfortunately we lost
a wonderful chess trainer grand master
from rear on cher a couple months ago
and um elizabeth vickery or elizabeth
spiegel now who worked with him
talked about a technique that he used
for when there was a student who was
like a lot
better than everyone else in the class
or sharper and neuron would have them
give the final move of the answer
you know so like if it's a six move
variation they would give the final move
so the other kids could still kind of
try to figure out how to get there right
i thought that was brilliant i'm
definitely gonna use it i'm gonna tell
you i i had the same technique
myself when kids who would put their
hands up really fast
before i even got the question out but
generally it wasn't the kid who was the
best kid in the room
it was a kid who just always put their
hand up right away pick me
you didn't even ask the question yet and
they knew the answer like how could you
know the answer i didn't even ask the
question
so i would say okay tell me what the
last move is
like what's the point of the line and
they then they'd have to stop and go oh
oh i didn't even look so i don't know
but very good
idea we need to give that to yasurawan
so that
we calm him down from now on from
throwing out the moves by the way
jeffrey has won his pawn let's switch
over to the game with ray robson because
this is a big point i wanted to make and
i talked about my my late friend ronnie
simpson and it
pops up so often on on this show one
thing he taught me about
when you count pieces
count only the active ones i learned
that from him
and the idea here is this move queen 86
that check pushing the king to g8
you can say white has only a piece for
three pawns
but the moment i play queen eight six i
have
three puns and a rook because that h8
piece
is doing another it's not in the game
it's doing zero it's not it's wondering
about the day
when it could one like once again be a
rook or or even
happen to be a rook that roams free on
the open air it ain't happening now
right now that rook is dead so white is
just up material
white is a big material white is a plus
three pieces
and a rook for that bishop sacrifice
if someday you get your rook in the game
but you know what with that last move
knight e3
that someday is looking distant as that
knight is headed to f6
and that's going to be mate absolutely
no question about it uh elshan's
position is
absolutely awful uh for me also it's
just this
black queen is terrible if right through
the magic of video you could put the
bishop on b7
to the d5 square then the queen
you know black's queen could roam a
little and maybe you'd have bishop take
c4 and queen takes a4 ideas
as it is the black queen is absolutely
stuck you're a
100 percent right that if you just count
the active pieces this rook on
h8 is terrible and you can see that
with this move rook e1 f5 is being
prepared
blast away as is knight e3 to g4
to d6 it all looks really really good
it went into the continuation we're
close to it we're close to the finish
knight a5 knight e3 queen c6
there's a good reason why the knight
came back to e3 we're seeing it now
knight d4
queen back to e8 this was his point to
try to bring the queen back
to help out and eject the queen knight
g4 is going to be met
by knight to d7 and you get the feeling
there
must be some kind of blow here f5
f5 screaming at me i mean just screaming
you see knight g4 on the board it's got
to be f5
f5 is coming it'll play f5 absolutely
and if you take we could play rook takes
f5 oh yeah and
if i'm on the board ray ray is playing
chess
folks yeah i'm stacking a rook
i'm stacking a rope yeah and after come
on f5 pawn five rook f5
pawn and then if you take again knight
f5 we're threatening queen g7 mate
and knight e7 winning thank you oh you
want to take the knight i was going to
take with the rook but yeah we're taking
with the rook we're taking with the rook
we're putting a knight on f6
i mean you could take with the knight
too of course that's yeah i mean they're
both winning right queen g7
knight e7 yeah flashy the other ways to
win here the aesthetic
the aesthetics the aesthetics of this
one is just too sweet come on just re
remember remember remember wise words of
michael tall
one win per game is all you'll need
one oh my goodness f5 look at that
gorgeous
move what an attacking game guys
he's sacrificed with d5 don't forget he
played
he sacrificed on c bishop takes c4 he
played d5 in this game
then he took a bunch of pawns he
consolidated the whole position
and now reset f5 this is a brilliancy
this is just more brilliancy elshon
looks like the guy who's holding the
wrong side of a brilliancy right now
you know he's like i don't want to play
simple chats against rey because he's
just
crushing people every game and you know
but he's trying to get those positions
king's indian wild french's sicilian
this is it for him and hey if he wins
this championship it will be his first
championship victory after so many tries
and it would also be the first if
jeffrey did it so we've got
two potential first timers here right in
the hunt for the crown
by the way if we're hearing that jeffrey
won his game
the game is already over oh
and important i thought we had a way to
go
on a minus score here at the u.s
championship nobody would have predicted
that
no way yeah i just thought that this was
a very important moment wanted to draw
people's attention to it
you have a really really good move rook
a7 here and i think that's probably even
a better move
i would have taken the pawn what can i
say rook takes a5 i love
having the material in the pocket and
i still have all of the advantages in
the position
oh my gosh what a terrible position
hikaru must have if the best he can do
is play bishop f8 to b7 back to a8
because now well look at the way here
they just said look at this next move
this one
it's not trapped well it's trapped in
the sense that if you take on e4
splat beautiful
wow beautiful yes look at that a pawn
ready to run
we pinned him on top of it and then he
collected more stuff he or even did he
just push his pawn or
well or did he take
he gave up before knight f6 but let's go
back and he resigned here did he
so let's go move back to rey as we watch
rey try to catch
that score were also catch
el shawn's king look what ray did oh my
gosh
he put his knife back on b5 to trap the
queen
oh that's better than checkmate trapping
the king and the queen
oh that's mean that's just playing e5
has just been played but we're piling
right now
there's queen g5 we can take on g5 g5
was played queen g5
queen g6 and then they're h6 and rook f7
and you resign
you don't you resign because it's
checkmate because it's made oh yeah
with that wow what a game
game of the tournament guys game of the
tournament
wow they've been some good games there
have been some great
they've been some great games i'm sorry
i got i'll take
this one you guys take whatever else you
want i'm taking this one
i like the ray robson sam shanklin game
too with
e4 e5 i mean you can have that one
you can have this one i like this one
what he did in this
game was sick that was sick
wow let's just go to the game of uh
linear dominguez for
just a moment where are you linear
linear dominguez is playing against alex
lenderman lenderman with
the white pieces linear with black oh i
see yes
yeah and oh he's up a piece wait a
minute
looks like an extra plea yeah he there
was a pawn
that was running up the board and lanier
said
push him baby a3 a2
a1 equals nine and you he had to take it
and lanier is lanier's gonna win his
first game by the way
that's a strange thing to say right
lanier
one of the favorites winning his first
game
like this is a very strange tournament
folks i mean i just
it's the the the three musketeers and
what they've been doing to the field uh
they
extended their lead and he's of course
he's up a piece guys so i suggest we
also
we could look at the game between wander
leong and sam shanklin is that one's one
minute for each side
jim franklin is up upon and has a great
position
but uh will he win it as he recently won
a game
the last round of yesterday he also won
a nice game so i think this would be two
in a row for him
and meanwhile a wander streak would end
did he beat alejandro who did sam yes i
think
i think he beat alejandro in the last
round yesterday
alejandro actually sank sad to say our
fellow commentator he's saying to his
third loss
yesterday was not a kind day at all
for alejandro now in this position after
b2b4
i'm thinking this this queen's got to go
i was going to go
knight to g4 followed by rook to e5
a7 a6 allowing h
in the words of somebody good what does
that have to do with anything
a6
a6 h5 queen d8 sam's really seizing the
defensive and saying
i wanted to defend against
knight b5 i was still looking for the
purpose of a7 a6 until
queen d8 was put on the board i have
five on the board
okay so if we take with the bishop
the bishop could land on d5 before you
could play
a5 takes g6 the rook found itself
trapped
i take it all back a6 genius queen d8
genius
kg7 genius defending everything that's
gonna that's gonna drop the clock
wow that's that's gonna get him that's a
nice
pinnamon winning baby yeah but with the
kids going down to g7
you don't see that very often well done
there's not even a way to
i mean just to make another no wonder
wonders just like
kind of amazed himself it's like wasn't
i attacking
yeah sam just got up from the board and
said you know like
there it is by the way our friend
alejandro is still playing against
darius riyarch so he has a coach first
student
but alejandra's got the two bishops
they're both down to one minute
so anything can still happen this is a
gorgeous bishop by the way it really
entraps the rook while also tickling
the knight only 100 looking very good by
the way just wanted to sneak in
the thought that that was sam shanklin's
third win in a row
right absolutely good point he had a
horrible start
and then he won three in a row who did
that
a wonder had a terrible start he lost
three
in a row came back on day two to win two
and a half
you know guys this u.s championship has
been ridiculously
you know contentious yeah up and down
belligerent everything i mean like
results that you couldn't possibly
expect to become commonplace
and uh wow wow uh
i'm still reeling from the idea that
people have
three three players have six out of
seven
like what that's a monstrous score
it's impossible it's impossible yeah i
like what
we didn't see it happening it's
impossible three players were six out of
seven one of them not named nakamura
one of them not named uh dominguez
right i mean those two
are boards two and three or boards three
and four of the olympic team
and they're not yeah and they're not
even in the top three g6 just played
okay what happens now bishop c4
keep attacking pin him and win them
right
situation knight has
no no no no so we're looking at bishop
c4
knight f8 defender bishop v6 king
king f7 we take this hoping to take this
guy
so you take this guy and somehow you
survive
it you you you slipped away
so uh this is the moment for
and he played bishop okay hold on you
play bishop d6 pack but then he noticed
that line you were talking about yes and
he kept the tension in the position
bishop d3 still going for the win let's
go alejandro
okay sorry 14 seconds left
but this well if he's gonna get it and
he
that's still a big if rookie eight
his idea is that bishop c7 is going to
be met by
knight d7 followed by knight takes c5 ah
nice one not easy now no it's not easy
alejandro might have let something slip
bishop oh the rook was forced to go back
to a8 well that's actually a little bit
of a relief
now how do we slip in the down do you do
it c5 is a weakness
c5 is a weakness and b3 is also a
weakness
that's about the score can we play for
f4 and f5
and bishop to d6 he hasn't break the
time pressure move
guys i love the move f4 in time pressure
whoa
rook c8 whoa whoa whoa
that was about giving the a pawn for the
f pawn
which alejandro did not take
f5 and he did he took on f4 and bishop
takes f4 played
okay now we've created a very severe
weakness this is
really really but yeah that bishop on d5
is just slightly annoying slightly
annoying
slightly and the knight coming to e6
will hit the c pawn this is stuff you
have to meditate on now all of a sudden
we talked about nervous tension 20
seconds left for alejandro
11 for darius 10 second meditation
rookie the 10 second meditation
g8 next yeah rook to g8 is
coming look at 100 prizes he can't
believe it
he can't believe it he's dropping upon
he's the one under attack for opening up
the file
well at least now bishop f5 tactically
um protects stuff rook d2 we have this
yes
and he's done it bishop f5 rook g2 would
be a blunder as you pointed out
jen bishop e6 overworked bishop which
would be
protecting the knight as well as the
rook g5 very quickly
as time trouble now he's blonder i think
he's going
to under darius right now at seven
seconds
yeah i think they're going to do a draw
with bishop or something
bishop g4 bishop james keep
it going but this is dangerous guys
bishop f3 pawn f3 and then
my rook might get into g3 can i just
take my rook
yes you could sacrifice rook even better
even better is to play f4 as a prelude
oh no this is gonna be
i think foreign missed that moment maybe
to play bishop takes e6
um he wanted to keep playing for the win
there he goes g3 and he's looking at the
age pawn well don't don't allow
rook b2 takes b7 check the apon could be
very dangerous so he played the
really good move that was a high class
move
rook a3 and i think
alejandro recognizes that things have
really gone south
rook takes rook b2 hoping still for king
c4 and rook takes
but i'm thinking he's way behind in
terms of the tempe here now
this pawn is just too fast oh look
what's happened king c4
it's it's a disaster for alejandro's
team three rook
takes rotations with check at least a
king moving uh
but the king can head to e4 easily the
king can go escort so his last
chance will be to take the c pawn and
hope for rain in that one because his
apon
would he just we just played very
bizarre a6
i gotta chop that inviting rook takes
rook g
rook b6 which is can you take the rook
can't he
no he took the rook he took he made a
mistake he could have taken the pawn on
c5
he could have taken the pawn on c5 with
his knight
oh yeah and now what's going on
he might have saved himself in this one
he had knight take c5
oh my god hold on saved himself we're
thinking darius is winning
no i'm thinking alejandro will now save
himself because he's got no we're
thinking darius is winning still think
that
he's winning he's going to go with
knight b7 and then he's going to
win this bishop but can this white king
yeah how does the white king get in um i
got to get in via d7
oh maybe i think this is a draw when you
come
over to g4 f3 i come to e5 e6
mm-hmm and then i try and king king c64
push push both queen at the same time on
the queen side i think
i think it's a draw yeah i think you're
going at the exact same time on the
queen side
what a steal and alex is smirking so
you're saying right here it was
knight take c5 yes that was the winning
move and bishop takes
rook takes and then you're going to take
bishop takes h3
bishop g1 and then f2 f3 and the king is
right out of the box by one two
wins and we win wonderful wonderful let
me refresh my board go back to the
current situation
but you're right knight takes c5 was
under any normal circumstance when you
when you have a little
bit more time to think i think all
all of the grand masters all of the
players in this u.s championship would
have found
that winning continuation that you
showed maurice
yep yeah and he is now
having being forced uh in this position
is allowed to make the draw but it does
look as though
king c6 is in the right tempo one two
three four
five six wait a second king c6 right now
takes one two three four
five one two three four five so five to
queen
while black takes four to queen so the
queen will appear
when just in time for white and they're
playing it out
they're playing it out king a6 or
king a7 c2 b7 queen queen
yep timing is just right
amazing results maybe the fair result if
you will
as white had such a good position and
black came back and
these two will have a good laugh when
this is over
wow they've worked together for years
and years
and now they get this draw and say ah
whatever
perfectly played
look with the times that that the
pressure that they oh
somebody's thinking i i saw a zero
zero on my uh i guess
i guess it was a zero zero zero eight
sometimes an eight looks like a zero
oh no i was pretty sure but okay
that it it like four moves
suddenly came black is hoping that white
does something exotic
like move his king away from the queen
so you can play queen takes queen
and promote the c pawn alejandra is not
in that battle form
that's not gonna happen this is fun game
though this was an
entertaining time scramble where
everybody was fighting hard you know
alejandra had a chance to take a
a drawlish end game and he wanted to
keep fighting and it backfired that that
does sometimes happen and blitz
but you gotta admire the desire to keep
going
wow wow it's such an eventful round in
our three musketeers
uh scoring two and a half out of three
against the opposition
they've just been mopping up it's just
yeah we're going to be at the point
where it's mathematically impossible for
anyone else to win
especially look at alejandro right now
he's just smiling like what the heck was
that
i i i'm pretty sure he was thinking that
when he played that move a6 this was
just like
you know my i'm down to my last cheapo
right you know it's not even clear you
have to take the pawn but
i'm down to my last cheapo and somehow
he swindled the draw
is that the only hall of the round guys
i think that was the sole drawl of the
oh no wesley of course
that happened so long ago i forgot about
it you didn't put it together with round
seven well
i i mean
and let's take a look at maurice's
favorite game wesley silver
san sabian just kidding oh
[ __ ] elsia ray this thing was gorgeous
look at this no trades for you heading
for the attack
and then knight d for the nicest hopping
you're good with it do you
like the way the knights hop on the
chest they don't slide they
hot i do like all the pieces pop they
get a little hot
[Music]
oh that was sweet and i went back to b5
oh sweet threatening and then trapped
the queen
i love the hoppity-hop pieces on b chess
and then the mating
mating finish king g7 is record seven
mates
wow that's nasty well
we told everybody at the start of
today's broadcast that we have been
enthralled by the chess of the first two
days and round seven didn't disappoint
jen our current standings we have
wesley so with six points and he's
joined by jeffrey zhang and
ray robson wow sam jacqueline clear four
um as one player who's kind of expected
to do well
um so everything else is a surprise
um as we have to say hikaru nakamura
almost mathematically eliminated from
the event now guys exactly
he'd have to win four games in a row
when he'd only get seven points
think about this okay if shank wins four
games in a row he would get eight points
so that's really the only other player
who has any chance now but with rey
and wesley all yet to face each other is
one of these three guys that means that
means one player out of that group
or is it even more than one has to
end with seven if they play each other
you know there are more points and
there's more points right you need to
have
at least three points in between those
three yeah even if they lose against
everybody else
right exactly so it would be seven and a
half
right no but they could draw no but they
could draw each other all of them no
they could draw each other and only add
it with seven
true true true yeah very unlikely
but they're guaranteed to get at least
seven yeah and lose all the other games
yeah it's not gonna happen and we're
gonna see a big score at the top and how
big is it gonna be
well we will be back in just a few
minutes for
round eight of the us chess championship
there's a lot of fantastic players and
tough opposition in this tournament
what do you hope to accomplish in this
event my goal is to get my title back i
won in 2018.
ultimately though what what killed me
about
last year was not everything that
happened to me
but rather that a true champion
when they face exceptional adversity
they man
up and they fight through it and they
win anyway and that was something i
should have done and i absolutely failed
to do
it's hard to say how i'll do i just hope
to do
well relatively well and get a couple of
scalps i really want to beat at least
one 2 700.
i mean i would certainly would like to
win the tournament like there is no
point in playing tournament if you don't
plan to
or not trying to win the tournament i
know it's going to be extremely
difficult and
it'll be hard to ask well i've played
everyone in the us championship and i
have a good feel about what i should be
doing
yeah i'm confident i feel good so it's
going to be very
bad if my goal is to try to win to win
it do my best
and try to finish in the top 3.
for the us championship you know i'm
just hoping to play a solid event
um you know hopefully get some wins
against some of the top players
um as as i kind of always say when i
play these events
i just want to play well and see what
happens i think
if if someone goes off and they have the
tournament of their life or they win a
lot of games they have a really great
result whether it's me whether it's
someone else
um that's just gonna happen you can't
really worry about that
so i'm just gonna look to play a good
chess try to win games here and there
and um
if it's good enough it is if it's not
then so be it but really just try to
play it play a good chat and then see
see what develops and and how the event
progresses so i'm the lowest of the
players so
no sweat no pressure so everything is
again so being here i'm happy
so i'm just playing my game i'm still
not
a serious contender i would say but i
definitely would like to um
to really play some good games and and
challenge uh
challenge the field there i mean i
always try to
to fight for first places uh uh but
um i know that yeah my results in this
type of format uh have not been great
this has been a tough time with covid
and
the way 2020 has gone what have you been
doing
personally to relax video games is one
of the main ones
so you know having my computer being my
workstation at my playstation
has uh has some negative consequences it
seems like i don't know
when to disconnect from one to the other
i think the big difference is that i've
been
uh talking much more uh to my family
i've
you know made more phone calls to my
family than i've ever done before
i think this is a perfect time for
people to really you know get
to know their families better and get
closer to them
i really enjoying uh just going outside
and shooting some hoops
and i also just a big sports fan in
general so
there are a lot of sports going on i'm
following everything
baseball playoffs are also coming so
definitely excited
for sports in general i like sports i
always liked sports so i
every now and then i will try to play
some tennis
or some football i play a lot of sports
basketball tennis soccer and i started
playing piano this year and i really
enjoyed
with no tournaments at all i'm just
studying i
i'm teaching a bit more writing a bit
more i'm streaming pretty much every day
these days
i took it to house the other day i think
i think what i do is normally since i'm
streaming in the morning i have
afternoons and evenings off so a couple
of couple of weekends i've gone for
hikes
i was out in san diego fishing a couple
days ago
so do a little bit of various things
that are completely unrelated to either
streaming or chest
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession
isn't a notepad camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility a journalist's work
revolves around the truth
finding it verifying it and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts
into context examining all the arguments
and including
differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories offering
facts that may have been omitted we work
every day to earn your trust for news
turn to st louis public radio
the st louis chess club world chess hall
of fame
and legendary world chess champion gary
kasparov
invite you to attend strategy across the
board the virtual fourth annual gala
a fundraiser to advance st louis through
the artistic
cultural and educational value of chess
strategy across the board will be held
online tuesday december 1st
from 6 30 to 8 pm central standard time
come celebrate with us reserve your
virtual ticket now
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton
of fun stuff for families to do like the
magic house
or the science center and if you really
want to be a
stellar parent come see all the new
stuff there is to discover at st
louis union station with a new mirror
maze
light shows and the 20-story high
st louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent
feel like a star st lou
is always exploring
hello everyone and welcome back to
the 2020 us chess championship as we
have
a thrilling round in store for you with
a very big game
check out those standings wesley so
jeffrey john ray robson
all with six and seven scorpion scores
and two of them face off right now it's
all about that jeffrey ray game
and well other important games but
that's the one to watch 12 points in
this game
that's really astonishing that uh we can
have 12 points in a game
truly and there are off as we see in our
v
chess um jeffrey as white has opened up
with the scotch
that's the move 3d4 on move
three and this i guess didn't come as
much as a
surprise to rey uh as he's played very
quickly into a main line with
knight takes d4 knight f6 oh
interesting uh way of play bishop what
are you talking about
opening is white do you think it gives
white a good chance for an edge or it's
more like a surprise weapon
more of a surprise weapon if uh if the
scotch defense
uh it does perf by force give white an
advantage
then it means that well that chess
is really not an equal game in that the
first move is really
uh big right uh but
i've never thought of the scotch if
there's an advantage to the scotch i
really
think it's in this variation with e5
queen e2
queen e7 queenie ii uh and i don't think
it's in the variation that
jeffrey chose bishop d3 d5 i've always
thought that this is a little bit
too sedate uh for
white and after queenie everybody
queen e2 i'm i'm confused
this move i've never seen and it looks
like ray has never seen it either
because he's looking at it
befuddled i guess you haven't seen it
guys oh
in this position queenie two right i the
only thing i can imagine is
you if i take you don't really want to
take i mean
this is just uh yes of course you've
doubled my pawns but
so what i've got the two bishops i can
easily give one of the bishops back for
your knight in the meantime i'll be able
to play bishop f5 i'll be fine
so i might even i might you might be
lucky i don't play bishop b7 in that
position
and give you my c pawn so i could play
play two bishops against you
so i mean i'm thinking
that jeffrey's plan is to play
knight d2 against d takes e4 but then
the question
i'd have is very good jeffrey how are
you
continuing the game after bishop b4
uh you don't the desirable c3 has a
refutation
queen takes d3 i think after d takes e4
i'm looking
and the main move is bishop cake's e4
but right here even more popular well
almost as popular as d takes e4 is to
just continue with bishop e7
bishop e7 okay i'm looking for more or
less for a refutation
bishop e7 is a fine move don't get me
wrong i'm thinking that
that white has done something wrong
jennifer and i'm looking to
punish white so that was why i would be
looking at moves like
bishop e6 bishop g4
f3 bishop e6 as a way to punish white
for having
transgress yes sir yes sir white
is a 2725 player
with a computer that is true
he forgot his breath and did something
wrong i think
i think he knows that he knows all the
nuances of this queen e2 move
and ray is sitting there as you see him
meditating and coaching
ruminating on this position he's like
and he has taken on you
what's the prep and knight c3 instantly
on the board that's allowing bishop b4
if you like
that we're in prep we're we're going to
be in race pres
in uh jeffrey's prep for a while
okay yeah it's probably equal
it's probably equal but it's not easy
and better for
for black even this position has been
played a number of times so bishop
really
um and if you play bishop b4 here what
do we do i guess we have to
at that point we could play bishop d2 or
we could play
if we play bishop e4 now what's the deal
you just take one you've got absolutely
positively
nothing with the white pieces
he's taking on e4 bishop takes
on e4 is on the board
he's done it nothing nothing i
i really i think jeffrey was just kind
of taking uh
hoping that look he's got a surprise
look at this craziness
right and he played bishop c6 instantly
he's not backing down winning
it was a winning threat for black
so like i said i i've been raised in
some kind of mode that
i would be in as well i'm saying that
white's made a mistake queen on e2 looks
pathetic
king's still on e1 i'm trying to punish
white
that's what rey is doing right ray
saying something is wrong with your
position
and not only can i sacrifice a pawn but
i'm getting going to get an advantage
after i hear your mindset yes but
look at jeffrey's clock he started the
game with 25 30.
so i just want you to match that number
up
obviously i'm joking 25 30. he has not
blinked
he has not blinked in his opening he's
playing instantly on every single move
and he's telling ray i've of course i've
looked at this
of course i've looked at this and i've
decided that this
is worth it no question about it and you
need to find all the moves because look
at the engine bar as well it's saying
the position is even
with black down a pawn which means black
has compensation
in its assessment but still the guy's
got 25 30 in his clock
he's not blinking he's putting the onus
on rey
to work it all out well that's a
shocking
v8 castles
um queen d6 uh
attacking the bishop looking on a good
for a good day to be able to play bishop
a6 to
secure an exchange so if you go back to
f3
i'll i'll go uh material hunting
um queen f3 that will run into bishop
g4 i assume um
rey has played rook b8 by the way which
is a move i've been looking at i've been
musing over uh i
i'm amazed captain instantly yeah
castles
he has more time on his clock than he
started with now right you have to play
castles because
bishop g4 is just simply a winning
threat it's not
it's a winning threat if the rook ever
gets to e8 when your king is in the
center
it's over castles and now i'm looking at
queen d6 so that i can
tickle the bishop he played in knight g4
and he played bishop
back to b5 instantly and now has even
more time than he had before he's got a
seven minute
body time he's clocked every move
with the moves but it's like really
strange because every move is instant
by the way bishop b5 was forced because
if the bishop moves to f3 to stop knight
g4
bishop a6 is lights out
so bishop b5 only moved now here i can
take
take take on b5 play bishop a6
and take this rook i'm looking for more
and ig4 threatening g3
instantly only move because and more
time again
four seconds extra every move he makes
he's adding time to his clock
is jeffrey john every single move he
makes is adding
extra time to his claw incredible
we're deep in his prep i want to know
how far his prep goes
i'm willing to see the move that ray
makes that jeffrey did not anticipate
because there's no way he's playing all
these moves instantly
one second off the clock on every move
if he hasn't prepared this very deeply i
think it's going to be pretty soon
because okay here we go even if you
remember everything at some point
it starts to get a little fuzzier right
so you double check things
we got it right now we got our answer we
got our answer
queen c5 is on the board this is not a
move that was in
his database beforehand maybe
yeah or it's not the top one so he he's
trying to refresh himself you know
one or the other um at least he paused
though
but uh just uh just trying to get the
zen of the position uh
you're threatening work b5 and bishop cc
you're signing like bishop c3 and queen
b5 right
right so you're sitting here as white
this is your preparation you're telling
me that jeffrey prepared and he
obviously he did you you
is white you've played the move g3 uh
weakening all the light squares around
your king and your bishop's on b5
and your opponent's bishop is within
instant striking range of the long
diagonal
that is really shocking to me i
i can't believe that this position could
favor white and by any measure
just g3 i mean look at it you just
expose the king and you you said jen
bishop takes c3 rook takes b5
that precipitated the move bishop to d3
and he played it pretty quickly guys i
think i think the
42nd thing indicates that he is indeed
still in theory
um he was just trying to double fresh um
something
i'm not sure but what you're saying is
is
that this is more than enough
compensation for a pawn that this is
kind of like a
a happier version of the marshall yeah
advantage black
yeah exactly who's going to try to check
mate threat with queen h5
yeah i'm thinking like wait a minute
this bishop is misplaced that bishop
needs to be on g2
just to make sure that bad things don't
happen to the king now it's very lucky
that the rooks are not connected
so that rook e1 rookie 8 attacking the
queen doesn't come with the tempo
but you're right it feels very
martial-like play
maybe this knight is on d5 in a martial
but
very martial-like attacking play
against white's king for the cost of a
pawn
and even this rook could participate you
know i don't know
but f3 in this position queen h5 f3
yeah i guess i think it's a dangerous
line to play
in a rapid time control against such a
tactical beast i wonder what jeffrey's
thinking and selecting this because
it seems like when you have a when you
allow yourself your opponent upon
sacrifice with such wonderful comp
it's particularly um unpleasant
defending and rapid and maybe
what he's thinking is that ray is going
to get down to
a minute trying to figure out how to
mate him and then he's going to
i'm not even joking i'm serious i know i
know
one of the most amazing games uh it was
this uh david navarro game where david
was white and he marched his king
in the opening all the way up to g7 and
he knew his opponent radislav would take
forever
and not find a mate and
lose on time which is exactly what
happened so
by the way yeah i was fa i'm too
fascinated by this position i wanted to
find out what was in jeffrey's book
so i did just open the engine to check
queen h5
in this position you have to be very
careful with the black pieces
queen h5 f3 okay
and if you now play this move 95
casually g4 shows up on the board
oops and suddenly you're in deep trouble
as black
you're in a danger of losing an entire
piece as you can't defend this knight
right and the engine gives white is
completely winning so that's the first
problem the second problem
is if you play bishop c5 check first
yes and and white then plays king h1
and if you feel like okay i can casually
play bishop to b7 now
suddenly knight e4 shows up yes
and the night on g4 is hanging the
bishop on c5
is potentially hanging because your
knight your queen is defending it
and all of a sudden white is ready to
move the bishop off of c1
and y will say well exactly how does
your attack work
so black has to be
slightly careful and not just assume
that
was that that jeffrey just came into
this line
without any sense and in fact we're
clear that jeffrey to me jeffrey's
bluffing on some level
black must be okay black must be okay
but he is figuring this is the kind of
modern prep that says
you're okay but find the moves because
your natural moves are not the ones that
work
you have to start finding serious moves
that prove
yourself in this position and it's
extraordinary to see it
but for example after bishop d3 the
engine gives bishop
d7 which
irks you a little bit doesn't it like
bishops i want my vision from the long
diagonal i don't like bishop d7
but it it guards the knight it brings
the rook
it connects the rooks it's going to be a
rook on the line so when you look at it
you go oh
it looks like a good move what does
jeffrey have in his
in his database against this one it's a
striking way of playing the opening
where you can play
forcing moves that may lead nowhere but
you want to see if your opponent can
find all the moves
and bishop c3 after a long think is what
he did
bishop c3 bc3 quickly played
uh i'm not a fan of this by the way
queen takes c3 bishop d2 i'm assuming
just to
protect the rook uh queen to c6
and
[Music]
rookie oh no he played and
i've turned my engine off but your your
bar
is showing that after knight e5 white is
the one who is better here
it did not look approvingly on this moon
i see the the bar on uh
on the screen there i i don't have an
engine oh sorry see what you mean the
bar we have here so this
for those in the audience wondering what
it means is we don't know what the
correct line is but we know that white
has a good line here because suddenly an
advantage showed up
just as the audience who's often
watching without engine they can they
kind of experience the same thing
they know who's better if they look at
that but they don't know why
it's kind of a nice combination in a way
for training then
you know look for a good move yeah you
don't know what it is
bishop a3 here how do you assess bishop
a3
bishop a3 forces queen a3 and then after
queen
e5 um and indeed ivar says that's an
edge for jx
because we have an extra point or it's
not the greatest pawn in the history of
the universe it's a double
pawn on c3 but on top of that we've got
our queen on this stunning square
exactly a powerhouse we're attacking c7
and yeah and twice better developed
mike's better he has an extra
10 minutes on the clock assuming he
doesn't think for 10 minutes
to play bishop e3 but you might play
something else
while we keep an eye on this game let's
just go to our game between elshon
and wesley because of course wesley also
is one of the players in the tie for
first and it looks like i won't go
through the whole game
but it does look like we kind of get a
reverse benoni
wesley has uh ended up with the two
bishops
no he's gonna he's got an extra exchange
oh i'm sorry i skipped the head looking
at the position itself
um i'm just i'm just saying wesley's
already up in exchange
oh very good uh well we'll get there
then uh
knight a5 knight c4 uh
knight b3 attacking the rook on c1
elshon said you can have that rook i
want to
put my knight on d6 and capture that
pawn on b7
okay and we are now
caught up with the players as bishop
takes d6
is the last move by
wesley so it's an interesting sack for
what we have
one pawn and not yet zero pawns
okay at the moment but you're you're uh
if you capture with the bishop of the
pawn that's a temple
and then you now you do have
a pawn for the exchange but
i'm wondering how curious pawn you could
have
yeah how good is that i'm going to be
threatening to recapture the d-pawn
and i'm also going to be hitting
potentially the b-pawn depending on what
you do with my rook
i don't like this i don't like this at
all on the other i don't like being
recaptured
with the knight bishop to c6
well obviously defending the pawn on b7
with both the bishop and the queen
they're preparing the counter exchange
sacrifice which will net black and extra
pawn
al-shawn white looks pretty bad at
actually
this line he went into this line by the
way
i could also play queen g5
at what moments i'm sorry if i wanted to
after pawn d6 i could also try to trade
queens with queen g5 because i think
it's going to be even better for me the
rooks in the end game i mean works are
very powerful in end games so queen g5
bishop b7 rook v8
and now your b2 pawn is under protected
as well and that's going to be more
obvious in an end game so i mean would
you have to play f4 here
creating more weaknesses i hate it uh
why did he have to play five why did he
have to sack an exchange
was it forced uh it backwards this is
exactly no before this move before
knight b3 yeah
yeah but he didn't have to play knight
c4 so this is the position
what is the is there a threat that i
think he was worried that the bishop
will come
to c6 followed by bishop to d5 and
knight to b3
he was worried that uh if he doesn't get
control over the d6 square el shawn was
worried
that black will park his bishop on d5
and just
kind of argue he's got a big edge and i
wouldn't
argue against that as it turns out well
let's just take a quick gander he did
play
queen f6 i liked your move queen g4 run
me
queen g5 as well jen um queen f6 was
wesley's choice and the players have
quickly gotten to that position oh he
did play queen g5
or so yes would you would you trade
would you trade what he did giving up in
exchange for this position
versus the position with the knight
potentially going on b3 with the bishop
on d
which no more i i think this position is
just terrible for
for white frankly uh i the problem is
you know if you put this b2 pawn on the
b4 square
i'll change my assessment and say you
know
it's it's it's not that bad it's
compensation
unfortunately as jen you know so
jointly pointed out the b2 pawn
is a very very significant target
in these endings where you get to go
queen takes c1 and bishop b5 the rooks
that rook will land on b2 with a thud if
the pawn was on b4
well now you can uh argue that if you
ever capture
on c4 i got two connected past bonds it
makes all the difference in the world as
it is i think el shawn's in real big
trouble
i would not have gone into this line i
would yeah this is
as you were suggesting don't sacrifice
the exchange
it wasn't find something else to do and
defend the position this was very
radical decision that he must have
misassessed
going into it by the way jeffrey did
play bishop to a3
rip the piece off of e5 and after bishop
e6 put his rook on e1
and he's after all the demonstrations by
black
it is it is a pawn to the good
slightly more active pieces not easy to
make this pawn work as it is a pair of
double pawns but
it's better to have the pawn if you're
going to play the scotch
where equality reigns supreme yeah
it's this position you might sign up for
a few times to say
okay i'm the one up the pawn and
just see what happens and i feel like
one possible idea for white is just like
you know
run the h pawn off the board just to
create a tiny little bit of a weakness
because that's the problem right black
doesn't really have
such clear weaknesses except c7 which
you know shouldn't be that
hard to defend especially since if i
take there you might be able to just
play rookies
not even defending e3 um i don't know if
it's a lot though
like guys how big would you rate this
advantage now i know
if you would rate this advantage plus
the 10 minutes on the clock
okay that's big but what what about just
the advantage
yeah as maurice like would you don't i
don't see this as
really significant for white like for
example suppose i play rook here
and let me just put some moves on the
board just for argument's sake
uh great you have an extra half pawn if
you
i don't know exactly how how to say that
you've got double pawns
but is is is the c pawn
as dangerous as the apon i mean that
that c pawn at the promotion square is
actually being covered
twice uh the promotion square for me
is only being covered once and i'm
thinking i get my pawn to a3 i go queen
b2
and i'm happy now you mentioned a very
nice
idea for white here after the move
rookie one
and maybe something that you really want
to consider more seriously
is not to take the pawn to simply give
me this guy
maybe you want to keep the rooks on the
board as well and play for the attack
here i'm suspecting queen d5 might be
okay so that's why after h4 maybe we'll
just move the rook
i'm not exactly but i know what you mean
jen uh let me just put another move on
the board for just a second
when you can get black to play h6 and
you've got a pawn on
h5 we should all know and be familiar
with this pattern
now this attack of the battery with the
queen and the bishop is really strong
because the pawn's on h5 and you can't
play g6
so maybe in this position after rookie
one by jeffrey rook b2
you shouldn't go pawn hunting you should
start
thinking in terms of uh a king side
attack
by the way uh yeah we do have a
a very big move i would call this a very
important move by
uh ray because that just gives up any
anything that i was saying that kind of
assault against the a2 pawn
uh you just take that right off the
table and jeffrey said
let me make sure of that and i'll play
a4 as well so i would say yes sir
yeah this position with black
against you i would be peeing in my
pants
yeah i would not be confident that this
is just going to be something i can find
the right moves to defend
this one feels more with the queen's on
than
the queen's off right this one feels
like
white has no losing chances
zero and it's black who has to find the
right moves now
the way he's played this position he
could have played differently we know
that he could have
sure sure maneuvered through this
differently but by playing the very
committal bishop takes c3 he decided to
go for this position
allowing white to completely suck up
all his initiative that it looked like
he was developing
and now it seems like one of those
wesley
sorry jeff craig keep calling jeffrey
wasn't that's always jeff
jeffrey decided i'm going right into
this end game
up upon you will have weaknesses the way
i have weaknesses as well i'd be able to
play
if you trade queens put a rook on c5
maybe put it up on a5
start trying you down play f4 or bring
the king into the game
and you're the one who's down the pawn
sure i may not be winning this position
but i'm not losing and i'm up apart
little
little squeezing this is a very
professional way of pl this is a very
professional way of playing
and what he was aiming for which was a
small edge
with with a big edge on the clock is
staring right in front of us
i would posit that this is all jeffrey
wanted in the first place
our small edge the big edge on the claw
and it's pure success as he's got 1940
and rey's got 7 18.
and i think it all goes into their
approach to chess like you see ray
robson is this player who
is such an aggressive player such an
attacking player like seems to be wild
seems to get kind of engrossed into the
beauty of the web of variations
and just like out tackles his opponent
and calculating
um whereas jeffrey is a very practical
player he is
a poker player of an event like he's
trying to
you know get you into a situation that
you don't like or you're uncomfortable
with
and so i i really think that uh this was
smart by jeffrey
um that said time pressure might be less
of a factor with such
simplification
well we all know that uh ray is so
susceptible to getting into time trouble
and you know these early problems that
jeffrey just gave him
you know jeffrey was thinking you know
keep thinking right keep thinking keep
getting into
uh keep that clock ticking i was
uh hearing what you guys were saying
imagining the simplification
what you're saying there maurice you
trade the queens you've got the
rook it's slide you know to c5 or a5
tickle the pawns a little bit the pawns
are separated you do have the extra pawn
how meaningful is it i'm still not sure
again the reason why i said this about
black is where you described
rey is how i would see the way jen
described
ray as i would see myself although ray
is a much stronger version
of wanting to have some dynamics
interesting play
creativity to play you yasser
with with you having technical people
where you can say
maurice your creativity there's nothing
here for you
you have nothing to think about you're
going to be defending for the rest of
the game
now you as black would say well i can
defend these type of positions i know
what you want
don't worry i can handle it but rey as
black
he's got 5 16 he's not flowing he's not
in flow
i think he picked this opening perfectly
for the opponent in front of him
it's not about the positions about the
situation and about the psychology
i'm i'm amazed that jeffrey went for
this line in the first place
look at the success it brought him i
mean the facts are speaking or at least
the evidence for this game
is telling itself the guy's got 1940 and
and
raised under five minutes yeah this man
yeah this middle bishop takes c3 just
giving up the two bishops
what looked like really solid
compensation for the night
and then not to take the pawn i'm i'm
kind of confused let me just take a
quick gander
at the game between elshon and wesley
when we left it we
thought that the exchange sacrifice was
not going to be work
well for el shawn uh you mentioned f2 f4
and i cringed
when i saw that move uh jen just because
i thought okay you're
exposing white's king that much more but
elshon probably felt
look i'm going down if i go down with
queens on the board
i've got a puncher's chance without the
queens i got no chance so
maybe f4 was just one of those things he
simply had to do
the position actually i think he's right
i think that wesley is such a brilliant
technician
he really has zero chance in those um
end games
i don't know if he has a chance here but
i can completely understand the logic
there are
a few pieces over there on the king side
and no defense exactly
got to do something because you're down
in exchange with weak
weak b2 pawn as you mentioned yes this
is
not looking good you do have a couple of
pieces over but it's a bishop and a rook
where do we put our queen to crack that
position open
what is it what is the sequence when the
when the guy plays bishop takes knight
on c4
right and you you're you're thinking uh
could i get some more stuff on the board
please i need more wood
right now d7 that's the problem
like if instead of taking on f5 you just
have
rook e7 instead of takes f5 e7
really nice that we could get that move
for free that would be so sweet
there's no funsies here there's nothing
no wesley's on to a victory here
we got to see whether or not jx or rey
can stay with him
is that still so clear hold on well what
one more look
oh hold on uh how did i want to do it
boy i think i just had a
in a brain freezing you tried you want
to try bishop f5 so you still have
rookie seven threat
yeah but the problem uh it's this this
this wish in zook that's right yeah
now there's no time for rook d7 okay
right
but what are you threatening where c4
and maybe queen takes that five years
queen c5
hitting your position right into the
bishop which is useful queen c5 beating
your mission
ah and the d6 protecting the sea floor
man no that's no fun work c7 you just
take that
and you're up a rock no that bishop
being loose on f5
ruins it yeah okay well
uh advantage wesley back to jeffrey and
ray again
these two players in first place and
that's what i meant by this move queen
a3 to d6 if you're not
if you're not trading queens and i guess
he decided not to do that
wasn't the queen on c6 like a few moves
ago
like i could have swore let me just go i
think it was c5 actually i think it went
wait a minute
wait a minute it was okay it attacked c6
i said yeah
i said uh correct it then it went to c5
so okay so this is
this is so strange this queen has been
dancing around
now no no progress there
there's a bishop b5 or bishop
e4 one of those two moves
i'm not sure which one as black is
hoping for some stuff
is apon hanging the a pawn would hang
and
looks like it well there's c7 is hanging
as well so you could trade and
well that's the trade that i was
actually she wanted to do
i know i'm more intrigued well okay
obviously uh
i don't want to lose the pawn but i'm
still intrigued uh
by jen's suggestion of running harry the
h-pawn of the board
uh to set up a battery now queen c6 does
have the advantage of tickling the pawn
that is true
what is bishop b5 though i had the two
options of bishop e4
or bishop b5 so where i like best c5 and
he's playing bishop b5 so
where are you winning the tempo you're
winning a very nice tempo now if you're
not going to f3 i i really suspect you
are going to have three i really don't
why did i play queen b6
a lot of rey's moves are beginning to
look a little mysterious to me but now
the movie and he's got 3 45 3
42 left on the clock right now
and he's going to i said the position's
more simplified so we won't get into
time pressure
i i i don't believe i don't buy that for
you i shouldn't have said that i don't
buy it
because just because it's simplified
he's still he still realizes that he's
under pressure
so um definitely a tough task for a ray
by the way last time
c7 in this position yes yeah yeah yeah i
was
i'm dreaming you know what i'm dreaming
of course is to deliver a mate on the
lights
if i sack my queen on c8 right now and
you cry exactly the
the back rank mate is the issue you know
when you think of how many
moves rey's made with this queen and
whoever made
luft is pretty uh sad
and he's like queen b7 guys he's played
queen b7
protecting the pawn on c7 but
not keeping bishop h3 alive yeah
alive that's what his main point is well
bishop h3 is not even a threat
because we have because we could trade
rook and attack the queen and it's made
so jeffrey just played rook d4
and said to your move bishop h3
is not on the menu the problem is it's
like as yeah saying like it's harder to
make look in this position because all
of the lift we can make is
kind of undesirable i guess we have to
pick one of them though right i mean
what do you say by the way this book on
the fourth rank
this work on the fourth rank is starting
to ask a couple of questions
you know we might go to g4 if your
bishop your bishop right now is stopping
that
might go to age four that rook on the
fourth
i'm not feeling this rook and you can't
trade it because c
takes and i guess maybe you could think
about trading it and
but then you could slow things down or
you could play
you could try c5 at some moment when a
queen can't take but he's played g6
but then earlier i mentioned with h4
becomes
stronger once you play that move g6
because then
i'm i'm trying to go h6 torpedo
h5 is going to be annoying especially if
i put my bishop on d3
because then i'm going to be threatening
things like take twice on g6 and your e6
bishop hangs now
i know i'm giving white like 20 moves in
a row so
ray has some defensive ideas probably
based on
shutting my queen out of e5 somehow guys
quickly
quickly we won't last long in this game
it looks like but we need to look right
now
the game with the game with el shawn
and wesley after e takes f5
queen f4 was played
queen f4 looking for it f takes e4
get lucky and play rook to e7
and win with that move as you're hitting
the queen on a7
and the pawn on f7 and yo
that's a nice little hope wesley played
bishop takes c4
and queen takes f5 threatening maiden
two
and after g6 queen f6 he's gone all in
on this attack he's hoping for bishop g6
maybe will be able to help him out and
save himself is this sound he's down on
a rook
right now turning the tables away wesley
who was up a rook
down a rook against sam shanklin and
managed a mating attack and wesley has
said go ahead
make your next move he's played queen b6
bishop g6 right now doesn't work
bishop g6 queen d6 yeah that's
his idea end of the story
there is rook there's rook e8 winning
your queen
right so but i'm not sure that is enough
okay so at the moment it's a rook so
probably
sorry let me put that very important
point
queen takes ea equitex d6 is defended by
the
rook but i can i can
decoy the rook uh yeah
deflect deflect the rock deflect the
rook because of the threat of date
forces you to take
and i can win the queen so it's two
rooks for
a queen and white's in there with the
shout
but you can get to rotate something
that's
that's a problem that'll be easier is
that there is a problem i want my root
back on e4
please could i just put the rook on e4
so i can sack on f7
yeah yeah that looks like a lot more fun
unfortunately unfortunately
uh this move queen b6 giving back the
material
not capturing the bishop looks to be
really really a key move because rook
takes d6 is
the answer these these guys don't fall
for tricks do they
by the way well what's bishop f7 what's
bishop f7
well no no no no this is the position of
maurice you can't get two moves
and he's taken he's taken he's taken on
c4
rook d6 and oh pushed all those pieces
that d3
check is a nasty threat big relief for
wesley now that he's grabbed this d-pawn
uh queen f4 played but can you just play
checking d2
check it c5 d2 it takes queens even that
i think is one
yeah i'm thinking that you just
sidestepped the move c5 for a moment
with rook d6
so that d3 and again just a minute i'm
thinking of this pawn where on b4
look at how what what a great difference
that would be
uh if the bomb was in b4 and not on b2
but rook d6
queen f4 on the board look i'm not going
to say cruising
but it does look like wesley so is in
command
in this game back to jeffrey and ray
when we left it
uh we thought that jeffrey was getting
an advantage and it looks like he's
increased his advantage by the way
after that move g6 he went and
rooked before g6 he went rook h4
wow the good jeff i was talking about
the rank
hyper aggressive use of this rook on the
fourth
finding the h7 square as a weakness i
like that and he's pointing out how the
queen on b7 is an
f you need that to defend so now if
queen f3 queen g5 bishop d5 is a nice
counter play
right and that was rook f4 and look at
this lean back to b7 all the way through
the free movements was it was it useful
yes
i think it was incredibly useful if we
imagine
the queen goes here
sorry sorry wesley did play that move
sacrificing the queen
with c allowing c5 so we just need to go
to it real fast we'll come back to this
as it looks like there's a little bit of
time just to go to wesley's game really
quickly
he did not play rook f6 and resignation
man i was trying to catch it before the
guy resigned
you were so close maurice it was so good
but
but you know c5 d2 and that was where al
shawn said i've seen it all
nice move indeed that's a beauty i've
seen it before and
just as you were saying i mean
you almost predicted this uh uh
jen that that pawn on b2 the rooks are
just so strong
once you win that pawn and el shawn just
gave it up
so wesley so he says okay
young guys
keep the distance catch me if you can
you bet uh rook f4 i thought that was a
very useful move
i just wanted to say that if if
queen f6 and rook takes e6
can be played jeffrey is gold that's
like game over so let's see how many
candidate moves here for
jeffrey though you can think about h4
you could think about bishop d3
trying to sack things work f6 queen f6
so he's actually sinking into a what
seems like it might be his biggest think
of the game i think he's been thinking
for three minutes
and what's the right moment he's got an
extra 10 minutes
let's start with the most obvious one uh
the most forcing is
queen f6 bishop can't move to the
desirable square h3 because
oops f7 instant resignation
so why why is f7 instant oh because of
bishop c4 coming okay
let's let's just point that out the
queen f7 king moves
check and then his bishop comes back on
the diagonal oops
so the bishop cannot leave the
protection of the f7 pawn however
queen f6 did set up rook takes
don't think you're getting me on the
back rank because i do have
bishop f1 so rook takes e6 queen f6
big time threat of rook takes e6
and what if just something like c5
trying to protect against it queen essex
was played
uh c5 i take
you just take oh cause you get two
and the same thing as before right no
because queen g7 appears i do have
seven but i think yeah i think you have
rick f7
oh made on the now we'll check on the
back rank starts actually
now it starts to get more annoying
because you can play work f1
right you can play rook f1 and queen h1
does that
queen h1 king e2 and your checks will
come to an
end and i'm i'm also
lost because you're just running queen
it's lost too many threats
okay all right well queen xx was his
choice
doesn't have to play c5 but somehow he
needs to get his queen into the action
because we can't get our rook into the
defense as why that bishop on b5 is so
annoying
between d5 no he played c6 i i think i
can't play c6
okay and now and so what if i have to
play c6 oh rookie six is taking on b5
now
and then rookie seven rook b1 is
actually mating finally yeah you know
that now you're
upset that you you traded off your
bishop but
having having provoked the move c6 in my
estimation
is really really good news for jeffrey
now
jeffrey can reset the whole thing he did
already
and it's not that i'm threatening g6
yeah i
am threatening g6 that's like that i
really i really think i'm threatening
h4 and h5 because against h4 you won't
be able to play
h5 because bishop g6 will but how do you
stop missing g6 right now
well if i move my bishop or if i defend
if i defend my bishop
oh because bishop g6 is a threat because
you're saying the key g6 there's rook h4
rookie 8 i still take on g6 what did you
have to take with the
why can't i take on g6 and then take
your mission
um just a moment he's played working
eight
he's played working he's on the board
he's got 14 seconds left
by the way 14 seconds and jeffrey has 9
23 to figure out how to drop the death
block i love this game guys because i
was so over excited to play the move h4
and h5
but i love how jeffrey kept it in
waiting because if i had h4 i wouldn't
have bishop g6 winning which
was just played on the board all of it's
on the board bishop g6
now he missed something because the key
point was if hd6 there's rook h4 so we
actually
deliberately left that square open for
the rook and not rushing with the h4
move beautiful
exactly now c5 played
that's got to be complete desperation in
this position
he's down two pawns his king's exposed
and he's hoping for
something lucky out of somewhere with
nine
seconds left against 904.
this is a hammer yeah it is and i'm
playing h4 right away
just making sure there's no rookie one
back rank mates no but really playing
for h5
i really think that h4h5 will do the
trick
uh but you're right i mean uh jeffrey's
got this game
he's two pawns up it's nine seconds on
his opponent he just
shouldn't rush right don't worry just
figure it out
uh by the way and if he wins he's tied
for first
i'm wondering has won a a very nice game
against darius church so
he recovered from his loss against that
youngster is showing heart man
yeah he's going to somebody you start
somebody who started 0-3 uh give the
young man a great deal of credit well
done a wonderful
move alejandro ooh
uh two pieces no
alejandro is losing this no question
about too many pawns
i mean holy smokes four pawns guys i
counted
for you yeah well thank you so much i
mean i
usually stop at one and two
sam savion uh versus alex linderman
sam
for coupons yeah
this looks like a fascinating imbalance
you know
this one looks bad for sam won three
games in a row and he currently lost two
in a row but it looks like their
fortunes are going to change in this
game
it does indeed it looks like he carl
with the white pieces
has big a big advantage big advantage a
third
one for jeffrey on the left let's just
if we're adding it up
he's got a third pawn uh you can keep
analyzing the folks can see
he's down to one second is ray and
finally actually made a couple of moves
and won the c-pawn back but he knows
it's over he's looking to the side now
and man pure greed jeffrey said i'm your
eight pawn two
with queen f7 check as the nasty threat
there so he's up
four uh he's up three pawns
i like right now for example i love
a c4 c4 not only push him baby but
you're setting up queen f7 by the way
we're gonna send
jeffrey the pawn grubbers uh
card uh club uh certificate
uh he played right instead
and cool visual move because it's also
attack and defense it stopped you from
playing queen d5 check and it threatened
queen f7 so kind of a
usual incarnation of double attack and
c4
there it is queen d5 check is a threat
queen of seven queenie six is a threat
there are too many threats
there's nothing too many threats i think
yeah i think ray's gonna it looked like
he flagged there but he didn't
but un unfortunately it's not gonna
change any fortunes here
rook f7 looks decisive with the
and queen g7 name looks just instantly
decisive
you don't have a moon queen and queen
ouch that is nice
you threatening rook f8 as well as rook
h7
so we're thinking that uh the finishing
touch
for jeffrey very impressive game yes
uh by uh jeffrey i mean
i ray yeah and just he's done it
and king g8 on the board so
rook f7 okay what's wrong with g8 if i
take the pawn and threaten
oh rook 870 does have rook f8 and
pretend that
he's still in the game that is true
that's weird
that is actually weird what the heck
rook f7 rook f8 and there's no
obvious blow it feels like there should
be
i mean c5 c6 c7 is rather mundane but
okay jeffrey said to take rook
that's one more pawn i am threatening
mate
oh that's nasty i can't check
yeah too many puns too many too many
too many pawns at any point he can trade
rooks if he felt like it but he won't
he'll just keep torturing you
and you're you're going to offer trades
in a second
relax on the problem yeah the moment you
put something on f6
rook f4 lane he's gonna offer the trade
and now
white's gonna say gladly accept it
thank you and ray keeps getting down to
one second but it doesn't really matter
here
no by the way a very nice touch king g1
a1 square protected very class
class and wow his preparation worked
perfectly guys for a rapid game
for a rapid game to work out those
nuances jeffrey zhang
and he has not played wesley yet when do
they play
uh jeffrey and wesley don't they play
they play next round don't they yeah
is the good stuff this is the good stuff
guys they got a
terminal they don't feel bad for ray
rocks in here
just looking uh at the game of sam
savion alex landerman that's
that's this crazy game where sam has an
extra
night but it's not so easy as the night
is awkwardly
placed i
didn't see the finish but i assume
lanier won
linear dominguez was playing alejandro
am i right
yes he did win yes okay so i'm staying
with sam
sevion and we just saw the move f5 i'm
expecting
maybe the move king d2 followed by king
c3 protecting the pawn
if possible he's trying to make that e
pawn into something
meaningful but we'll have to come back
to it
but at the moment just keeping the the
knight
entombed on that square that's the
annoying thing right the knight just is
on the i mean put the knight on c4 be a
boss
and and it's just good wonderful right
so the knight you know you you want the
pawn on b3 to be captured so you can go
knight to c3 to b5 bring that back into
civilization and then you'll see
rook and knight uh ensnare the the king
did this move f5
i mean it's mildly annoying right
because yeah well more than mildly i
mean
he looked at that position this is very
damn sad
but maybe too practical a decision sam
said you know that is such an annoying
night to try to rescue
i'm just going to give it up uh i'll go
into a rook and pawn end game
upon ahead and by the way while this one
turns out to be more of a technical task
than we expected
do you guys want to see her nakamura win
his first game in a while
all right sorry i thought that game was
over okay i don't think so it's still
good
as far as i see okay played
um he's just played the move rook e8 and
you know hicario is not only up in
exchange but
sam's king on e6 also looks
in peril honorable but are there any
tricks here if like
um if you play rookie eight does
queen d2 check do anything because
obviously if we could get into an end
game we'd be thrilled
we could play queen d2 check and
unfortunately rookie 8 is actually a
check but
yeah after 98 if we could somehow trade
queens we would be thrilled but look at
this rook b1 that's a good move
as really queen before queen
g for chad i'm sorry i forgot i forgot
about green before
no but but it is a sparkling move
because it looks like he's going to mate
the guy
i didn't see it yeah i think his idea is
not to play queen g4 so much as
okay so they could play rook h7 or work
eight seven
rook h7 tickled the knight
so that the queen can sometimes uh swing
to h3
so let's say queen before rook h7 so now
the idea is to swing here go
check and queen h6 as well as check
and maybe rook rook 86 is very cool he
played rook h6
okay six looks like a good one as well
very calm who defends that
queen essex and work f sex mate
okay so if the queen drops back i guess
you have to do it you have to go back to
e7 well if i go back to f8 i may run
into rook f1 so
exactly they have to go to e7 no but
queen g4
check queen g4 checking rook f1 is going
to be lights out
oh oh oh oh oh oh this is even stronger
yep
or that is even stronger so he went back
to f8 did sam but now he's going to have
his feelings hurt when the rook shows up
on f1 and there's
no defense to rook takes f6
but look at mclemore shaking his head
and it's disgusting i wonder if he's
thinking about a previous game
because this one looks pretty happy
that's what i'm saying about naka
sometimes he shakes his head in disgust
when he's totally
when he's winning yeah sometimes he's
totally losing it it's a bit odd it's
just like i think it's more
like he's maybe thinking about some
analysis that he messed up and it could
be
better or worse because it's a little
confusing
okay but queen g4 check about isn't
quincy for checking
rook to f1 on anything you do just
crushing
well i do have rookie six queen g5
oh very nice he's played queen h3
i think there must have been a plethora
of wins
here for hikaru because he seems to be
he's jacking oh he just trapped the
queen he's just dropping
something nasty that's a good oh that
was nice
nice i'll take this part with work take
c7
yes that was nasty that was artistic
oh beautifully done sam sits back
resigns as they both now
have an even score that
really took the wind out of sam shanklin
sales he
he he'd won how many in a row three in a
row
three in a row and was was creeping back
into the table there but man this was a
nice finish by
uh nakamura had lost two in a row so he
needed to get some win back in his sales
exactly all right we got one game left
in this end game
i don't like to go back now this is a
classic
classic ending of four versus three but
this time you have an
a pawn and i remember
i was on the appeals committee for the
world championship match in buenos aires
in nineteen thirty
cappablanca versus alekhine uh but
in that game uh alekhine had
the rook on the good position and he
won it four versus three here the rook
is i'm going to say in the bad position
on the side
g5 what a move by alex
that's extraordinary wow that's
insisting
that you cannot win this game to save
your life
you make this move well what he's really
saying is i'm going to park my king on
g3
if you ever try to crawl your king all
the way over here
to the queen side so that the king could
then go all the way up the board and you
can promote your pawn
for a glorious victory he's going to put
his king on
a g3 and get counter play what a move
g5 i'm not sure b6 doesn't do anything
really trying to win your gpa i'm trying
to win exactly
um uh i i'm assuming you can win it
and you can try to play maybe
try i'm trying to win your age pawn for
free but actually yeah
well this ending i believe
is true this one is a draw i was trying
to win your age pawn
so but that looks like it should be a
draw yes
yeah looks like it should be a draw
because when i take a king g6
and i can't play g4
and this does nothing so uh
we're back to this moment so what sam
did is he said okay i'll go along with
your agenda
i'm going to take this pawn i'm going to
take
but this time i'm going to bring the
king close
to the king side before i give the check
and go after this f
pawn so he went king jiwan
in order to stop the king from coming
here but but he's close to a draw right
here
uh is lenderman
why because you're gonna have to give
ground as soon as i go rook here
i'm threatening to take with a check
you'll you'll have to back up
which is exactly yeah but he played rook
he played rook a1
so now you your king can't enter you
can't play king h3 because you dropped
me
yeah don't do that don't worry kg5
played luckily you can't touch your king
in um but in rapidly
oh what i was thinking look this is what
i was thinking right here look
you see this rook g7 check and now black
is threatening rook
a rook ah1
stalemate exactly nice one yeah
so there's nothing to do white can make
no progress
and he had to play this check chief and
marie
this is looking very drawish now
yes i'm not even sure that he needed
rook
here but he did it rook h3
[Music]
and in some tough end games guys i don't
understand isn't king g6 a draw
isn't king g6 an auto i mean it play
maybe h3
and and if you take i play i play
king g6 isn't that an auto draw
well he's played rook check
king h1 okay i'm having a hard time
he's doing the direction mystery moves
uh
king g1 is good king h4
we don't buy it no i i certainly don't
buy it either
uh i would probably play rook check just
because i'm confused
by my opponent and play back you know do
it the old soviet school of chess you
know
make a repetition show your show your
opponent who's boss
oh look at this now he's going down the
ball sam
uh rook
here it is a repetition nice defense
there by alex slender
and that's why you study your end games
guys he's not a piece
he was on a night sam is disgusted right
now
there's no question sam is is yeah
it's not easy being a rook and knight
versus rook uh
that's the second time we've seen a draw
at that ending of rook and knight versus
rook
that lenderman saved it was the same one
he saved it twice he must be smiling
saying i know the drawing
what's the secret
let's take a look at the end of that
majestic
game by jeffrey zhang against ray robson
to grab
the joint typer first with wesley so
exactly this v chess is such a nice
animation
check this is just a straight beat down
it doesn't take any animation to see
three extra pawns
trade down and make it easy after this
move
king g1 saying you have no more checks
jeffrey from the beginning of this
tournament was his technique and even in
the interview he said like yeah my
technique has been good and that sounds
easy enough just good not some huge
superlative but
when you play one good move after
another in rapid chess
well that is superlative it's all about
the string of them
never making any big mistake always just
kind of keeping your edge
and driving at home and and that's what
jeffrey's doing here
it's so hard to keep control so
hard to keep control and a big reminder
as we close out the u.s championship
tomorrow
we will have our combined closing
ceremonies
that's going to be tomorrow after
october 29th at
five o'clock central time immediately
after the u.s championship pretty much
um depending on whether or not we have a
play-off and you can watch online on the
st
louis chess club youtube or twitch
channels and
it's gonna be a lot of fun we're gonna
have a combined ceremony for
all five championships as we celebrate
our october winners
and before that though we have to crown
a u.s champion
so we are going to be back in just a few
minutes for round
nine of the us chess championship
there's only three to go
as jeffrey zhang and wesley so hunt down
that crown
[Applause]
i'll move you right back
everybody's been talking about sam's
intensity so much energy he's burning
here
um and in this position it is his move
what are those eyes looking at maurice
much respect to awanda liang for the
maneuver that he just played
in this game and i think that sam
staring at this board
is wondering what the heck is really
going on as the youngster
is putting it to him this position is
all about this lightsaber
square bishop that's what sam's thinking
how do i take advantage of that
he dropped this bishop back to e2 and i
wonder said i have no problem with you
there
develop your piece and i'm gonna put my
knight on e6
and it's gonna be my dark square bishop
that has something to say in a second
because your pawn on g5
could get nibbled bishop e7 could be
coming quite shortly and you still even
though you've got this file you haven't
solved the problem of full coordination
and how do you
build this position this pawn
controlling central squares it's not so
easy to put anything
onto great squares for black for white
in this position
and a wanderer does have some intent to
play the bishop here
think about trading off something on
this square and don't let a pawn storm
start to come down the board then you're
going to be wondering about your king
if you're not making me think so right
now the engine is giving
a little bit of an edge to white still
but i'll tell you if you're sam
if you would have prepared this line you
want to thought this is really good for
me
according to the engine but looking at
it now you might go
why why is it that good for me right and
i think he is being challenged very much
so by a youngster who has played
wonderful chess in this tournament
winning his last game first time in this
event
drawing three of the top 10 players on
the planet
his future is bright indeed and
he's putting a challenge right now to
sam shanklin who says i need to win i
should be going for a win maybe you
don't need to win
but this is a great opportunity to do so
not so easy in these championships
it's a really wonderful pivot we saw the
knight go to c5
you know the b3 to c5 back to d3 to b4
provoke this move now guess what i'm the
best
wow because you're not threatening takes
on before
just hammering on those light squares
again the light square attack
the light square bishop the light square
attack the light square initiative
he's playing instructive chess right now
is this his best game of the tournament
which game would be better than this one
in terms of dominance clarity
just this is
for sure in terms of one-sidedness and
complete uh control i like this game
the game with ownership he outplayed him
really from start to finish and
what a nice
for sure achievement there so other than
that what other game i can't think of
another game that just
he was grinding but this is
this is it looks gorgeous this guy
yeah he looks like a mad scientist
almost those eyes are just like
oh i'm gonna experiment on you right now
yeah and
he's not gonna end good i'll take the
left arm i take the right arm
and you'll be running around and then
i'll just chop the legs off i mean it
looks
he just looks like pure focus
concentration intensity and he knows
it's
right now the moment and only after this
is over will he just relax
but i don't know if he's gonna relax
that night
i think he's gonna be all smiles cheesy
he's gonna be bouncing that's
but you know during the game it's a
different thing how nazi was during her
win when she won
how intense she was at the board until
she finally won
and then the emotions the embrace of her
husband
had us all uh just wet eyed watching
that joy and the same thing
with sabino and she won as well when
it's unexpected when you didn't realize
that this could happen you hoped it
would but then suddenly it happens in
the most magnificent way
but still he's got a game to finish and
he's adjusting his opponent's pieces as
he he knows he's uh
completely dominating here bishop bb5
played
uh and looks like a wanderer what did he
do
king d7 and then he's moved his knight
back to d3
yeah he pivoted back with his knight
eyeballing the pawn and the resignation
sam shanklin he pointed at himself he's
so ecstatic look at that smile he
is on top of the word ecstatic sam
shanklin
i've never seen sam smile like this
before u.s olympic
team member it's been a fairy tale for
him
this is pure joy look as we see people
congratulating him
[Music]
the st louis chess club world chess hall
of fame
and legendary world chess champion gary
kasparov
invites you to attend strategy across
the board the virtual fourth annual gala
a fundraiser to advance st louis through
the artistic
cultural and educational value of chess
strategy across the board will be held
online tuesday december 1st
from 6 30 to 8 pm central standard time
come celebrate with us reserve your
virtual ticket now
so because of the pandemic we were
forced to work a little bit differently
for our
chest productions and it's been really
interesting
and quite a learning experience as we
got lights and backgrounds
sound equipment all mailed to us and
we had to figure out how to set it up
properly you know cheating is a really
big and important issue in chess
particularly
online chess so the arbiters really have
a lot of work on their hands
of course there are cameras that can be
in the room so they put
not only not only do they monitor the
computer screen that the player is using
but even have a camera behind them
to make sure that nothing nefarious is
going on
it's remarkable that everybody is remote
in all
areas of the world i'm in hilversum
holland
kind of a suburb of amsterdam jen i know
you're in philadelphia maurice i know
you're in brooklyn new york and the
players are all over it's all
rather seamless we all transit
our signals through st louis the truck
there and all the magic happens
but whether you're in person or whether
you're actually
working online remotely to be able to
connect
the power of voice you know it just
makes you
realize how grateful we should be when
we get
to meet each other in person and
everybody is healthy
and safe
[Music]
hello everybody and we've got one more
round today
as wesley saw and jeffrey zhang is
sitting at the top of that table with
seven points
i disappointed ray robson really tough
because
um such a good chance for the crown this
year guys for him was such a great start
and with no fabiano carolina in the
field
so um definitely sympathy but you know
what he's the one guy
outside those top two the tournament's
not over yet he could still go on a run
in his last three games so we've got to
keep an eye out absolutely
most of the chances it's gonna be wesley
or jeffrey
speaking of wesley and jeffrey jen
setting around nine pairings what do you
think our marquee match-up might be
well that's the one guys is wesley
playing late against jeffrey
um reagan and chicago also are going to
be a very entertaining game no doubt
absolutely
and um those are the two big games yeah
that's
those are the two big games and of
course we love to watch the other
battles as well
as they've got great jazz but in terms
of crowning a u.s champion
we're looking at those two now by the
way one thing that i didn't mention
when jeffrey won that nice game against
ikaru
was that um it hearkened back to that
game where hikaru won with the bomb
cloud against jeffrey
now granted that was a blitz tournament
but a lot of people were saying that
mustard really hurt for jeffrey
so a little bit back a little bit of
payback you know
you know why i didn't i didn't see it
that way because
i didn't see it as that embarrassing for
jeffrey i mean i i think any time you
can lose a blitz game when
you know you're winning it happens to
everyone even the best players in the
world
but the but the fans i think were just
like wow poor jeffrey and
hey today in the us championship he's
the one
who is chasing wesley so for the title
yeah i personally felt it was
disrespectful but hey
uh i have to admit that uh
hikaru has a really wonderful
um stream and let's face it he was
playing
playing for his stream is basically what
he was doing there
but still yeah i think jeffrey felt
that his victory over her caro earlier
was that extra little
special and by the way i will say he's
not chasing wesley for the title
they are neck and neck for the two
exactly they are now
tied up in a big time game and whatever
happens here could just dictate
everything we should point out if rey
loses
and actually i would say ifray loses
this game
it's over it's over because
one of these players will go to at least
seven and a half and he will sit back at
six
and we can just say miracles can happen
for sure but in practical terms it's
over so jeff
so right now it's a huge game for rey
against nakamura as these two they may
end up in it let's say
drawing the game as well and go to seven
and a half ray can not lose
or else we'll have these two we're
saying are going to be the ones who
might win
i should also point out a quick stat as
we see here a rouser
let's switch that make that up a
shreshnikov on the board as we see
v chess showing the position there
quick shreshnikov jeffrey going right
into this line that used to be played
incredibly so in the 90s yes you
remember back in the day everybody was
playing this thing
kromnic laco and everybody else going
into these sharp super sharp lines
so they're testing it now but i just
wanted to give this one stat
that ed gonzalez told me he said
we got to go all the way back to the 40s
when samuraszewski and isaac cashdon
started that championship i think it was
43. i have to do a quick check
started that championship seven and a
half
out of eight whoa
that's the difference to start they
ended up tying in the end at 12 and a
half
out of 15 and roshewski won the playoffs
so
this is not this is not a record that
we're seeing right now
seven out of nine uh seven out of eight
excuse me
as seven and a half out of eight was
actually done by two players before
well something we've said a lot in 2020
this is not normal
this is not normal no you have to go
back uh quite a number of decades
uh wesley and jeffrey are playing an
incredibly topical line of the seventh
cough i remember
uh former world champion rustam uh
ruslan
um what is ruslan's last name
no no not rooster
he did a really wonderfully uh well
annotated game in new in chess
in this variation and uh explained the
nuances
and it was just like wow it was so so
nice to read the perspective of the
world champion
and g2 g4 now we're in
the wesley sew kitchen of
opening cooking here as g2
g4 what a time to produce
this big time move i feel like i've seen
this move before and i feel like it was
wouldn't be a surprise has been played
before
i feel like wesley was the one who
played it when i when i saw it but we'll
find out more details
maybe even in a u.s championship or
maybe it was a grand chess tour
played 30 times says
yeah and wesley has been on the white
side of this before hasn't he
and is bishop f4 the main response by
the way to g4 gen
you said 30 times um i think that varus
was
referring to that position um no wesley
games in this though
okay really so bishop no wesley games
three
on the board and then yeah this seems
they're still following fury after queen
to f3
and now
bishop e6 and or a
five wow and so what's the idea which is
uh that if you take on f4 too many lines
are open
well i'm assuming
beta4 oh i went bishop e6 what would you
prefer
either one a um let's try a5 go ahead or
bishop b6 fine too but in either case
basically you're saying you have
lots of compensation here right i was
just thinking a5 super direct because if
knight f4 upon f4 queen f4 we can just
keep going with b4 and like just
go after opening lines asap typical
especially
of territory typical yeah
they sack pawns for no reason in this
restaurant and
when you look at it you go wow look at
that all the pieces are in perfect
squares the attack is flying
you you're busy pushing pawns to win a
pawn and it's no big deal but i will say
disgusting the most important thing
about this position
is that it's wesley who has blitzed out
all his moves
and jeffrey who we saw do the same in
the last round
now staring at the board slightly
concerned
at this last move as he's not doing what
he did
to ray it's being done to him
well 20 almost 25 minutes by wesley
23 minutes by jeffrey to get to move 16.
these guys have been playing at a pace
uh bishop e6 and a5 the two main moves
and i guess
for jeffrey he's very familiar with this
position
he just hadn't decided maybe before this
game which
line to play bishop e6 or a5
well i think it's far from like a main
main line right because 30 sounds like
not a lot
when you're talking about the specinikov
it's such a popular light
so it could be exactly you booked that
once but and was like oh black's good
here but didn't really remember
all the lines now which one attracts you
more yes if we play bishop e6 what
exactly is the counter play idea there
because i
i got it with a5 i was trying to play b4
but you were trying to show me bishop e6
as well and now
i i wasn't sure uh if i'm supposed to
play bishop e6 with the idea
that if you take my bishop i i'm not
just gonna
give you the pawn right away but i was
going to try to move queen f6
and how's the game after g5
right so something like this so
i'll park my knight here and
think it's okay i mean i agree i have a
backward bond on the default
that i've frankly i am
not a sicilian and especially players
are not defending the pawn
they don't care like don't care a5 you
go for it and he's got
okay a5 so
that was jen's original uh uh play as
well
like even with bishop e6 i think you're
giving up upon and
again pushing your apon and going for
the play
so bishop v6 knight f4 takes queen takes
and go
just hop on your train and make this
b-pawn
into the most significant thing on the
board is this play
you you better have specific a concrete
way of dealing with it one thing you'd
love to do is take on b4 with the c
pawn and then play the move a4
and shut down the activity on that side
especially since there's no easy uh
easy way for the knight to get it the
problem is just move b3
at the moment and there's nothing that's
closed down
so this is hard that's it so but i
wasn't setting
out anything exactly that's the typical
thing you do in this position
in order to shut down the play but the
problem is the speed of it that's why
you don't waste any tempo
defending the f-pawn like you want my
f-pawn congratulations
snack on it because i've got play on the
queen side that's coming right at you
so that's why i say okay ignore and go
okay so uh let's say i don't uh
i don't i i just try to play with the
extra pawn for a moment i
play a b b ab4 so
then my rook is at least alive uh
i tried to do that in a certain in other
games where i play a b
and develop my rook uh i play bishop e2
so i don't know i'm protecting my pawn
i'm developing
i'm assuming you want to take i'm not
100
sure oh yeah okay there's nothing else
concrete bringing the rook in uh
bring the rook i'm assuming you mean
rook b2 so
let me chase that rook
uh backwards or if you want to defend it
i don't know
no i'm not really interested just yet
but i'm wondering what you do about
you can castle after queenie's seven oh
no but two pawns will be hanging so
queen e7
oh no if we need seven losing sorry you
can take my row you can take my rook
today because you have king d2
you have king d2 at the end of this so
let me be careful
and maybe rook h3 or king d2
this is oh i saw a check my apologies i
saw a check
i'm ghosting let's back up rook b3 here
rook b3 here okay so
let's let's tr let's get rid of your
active
pieces and i just feel like you're
defending
and i'm not fi oh yeah take on take on
a3
yeah so all of this
for one pawn well
we're just we're just gonna keep going
uh knight no queen e7
want to play knight e5 on the next move
i'm just going to make sure you don't
like you're not castling because your
h-pawn's hanging so
every move i make i'm hoping keeps
creating threats you're
you're complaining uh not giving me a
chance yet to
do what i want somehow i didn't get
everything though
you still can't castle yet by the way
uh is this a novelty jen
what uh jeffrey played jeffrey did not
play
a5 he did not play bishop e6 bishop b7
was his choice
wow um well yeah bart um agrees that
the two moves mentioned were the big
ones in the database
they should be e6 yeah um so let's check
check out what the difference is if
knight f4
pawn f4 queen f4 i guess you guys are
always i'm sorry you guys are always
giving up the pun like like it's
standard
is more happy because the bishop on v7
is really well placed
than it was in some of the other lines
okay uh
oh i'm talking about your move yes you
want to you don't want to give up the
pawn you want to play queen essex
no no no no you you guys are are giving
up the pawn like it's standard so
i i just want to see how it goes if you
do give up the pawns yeah okay and then
what would you do
eight or ninety-five what do you got
yeah right rookie eight or 95 let's say
castles
okay so in my world i want to play h5
and h6 in your world
you want to i don't know a5 b4
queen i got a knight on c2 makes it a
little bit hard for you to get in
b4 doesn't it when none of that took
place
as after bishop b7 it looks like we have
another
quickly just g5 very quickly
like for for wesley this move bishop b7
was not a surprise maybe
is that like the computer recommended
move
uh i'll turn it on
so bishop b7 bishop g2 was suggested
and bishop b7 bishop g now that
i don't think i would have played yeah
that's just the castle but uh
a5 bishop g5 was the recommended move
before
bishop b7 yeah that was theory that it
actually yeah that was theory so bishop
yeah here g5 and the engine now says
knight a5 is better for black
he played rookie eight already did jeffy
he played rookie eight immediately
knight a4 was slightly better from black
according to the engine
yeah now but now precipitating that's
that's a nice move by the way
precipitating
chaos because now you can't play for
knight f4 and queen f4 because of bishop
e4 at the end of it
uh let me just put that on the board so
our viewers can
follow so knight a5 the engine
recommended move
opening up an attack against the knight
and if white
decides to now clip a pawn bishop takes
e4
is really annoying uh because queen
takes before rookie eight
but he has played rookie eight as a kind
of a preliminary move
to uh knight a5 well what did what did
wesley have for bishop b7 i mean for a
knight a5
i don't know it's hard to believe he's
in his prep here
i maybe after g5985
intended to defend his knight uh maybe
maybe with his rook i really i'm at a
loss uh
it's not it's not my my position
strange at any rate there are they are
now in a position who's probably not
known to theory
and a and rookie eight has been played
and jeffrey pausing so a
couple of strange moves by the players
we're probably out of book i'll leave
that out tavara to let us know
but this position is not
uh is not going to be easy because this
is a very chaotic position with white's
pawns
already on g5 and h4 black is
fully developed he's ready to sacrifice
material
and it's the kind of position where the
fresno car players are always
happy to sack a pawn in order to get
play
and here goes wesley he started by
taking on f4
so ef4 i take spawn takes i assumed the
king was going
queenside uh when you're playing
g4 h4 g5
normally speaking your king is not going
uh
to the king side but the problem here
and he's done it
so yeah okay he's he's he's played it
i i was about to say the problem here is
this pawn on e4 might
come under play under fire after knight
a5
not that easy to defend the pawn you
can't play the desirable rook d4
that walks into knight v3 check
like you will not you will not believe
the next move now you got me
looking at this b4 for black
a castles by white b4
for black oh my goodness okay i have to
take that i mean
i can't let that guy just live knight
takes b4
wow okay that's that's a visual
okay that okay what can i say gotta go
for it
bishop now the rook is hanging right
so queen age three so that we don't lose
the whole thingy
whole thingy i guess queen a5 and uh
just ask you what you're going to do
about your king you also got to check
rook b4 and queen c7 jack
b4 is the best move keep it going and
queen c7 shag
you're escaping on c3
oh i have to go queen c3 well queen c3
though the h1 work now hangs for nothing
right
well i probably love this body count jen
any ending will be favorable for white
right no better was cool maybe we don't
take it we play like queen b7
better was quinceanera offering a trade
of queens this way
queen c8 check oh that's surprising
wow don't forget black is up a pawn
right now
hey guys so why what was wrong with you
seven queen c3 queen b7
threatening bishop h1 and rook c8 queen
c7 queen c3 queen b7
threatening the rook on h1 and the rook
on ca i think
i'm going to be happy more or less to
get a position like this where i can
you know i've got two rooks i i i yeah
i'm in there
but um what a wild what
crazy chat yeah bishop bishop h3 refuted
that line by the way bishop h3 after
queen b7
was bad the castles i mean
if we see b4 uh that uh to quake
to quote our world champion
magnus carlson that would be alien chess
um knight a5 looks like a more normal
move knight a5 looks
far more a lot of people would play with
the idea that you're i would
yeah you're throwing e4 knight b3 check
knight c4 coming in discerning
variations exactly it looks like a nice
all-purpose move
right right i mean that i mean my
natural incon
inclination would have been to just put
as much pressure on
against the e4 pawn as i could and so
you know directing the knight to c5 the
bishop on b7
but that i have to confess that move b4
man if that works that's just like
and by the way maurice if you
if we had played c3 takes b4
is it oh it's still the same business i
guess knight b4 and bishop e4
makes sense wow what a concept it's
insane
and i don't know if jeffrey is studying
it you see his face
just scrunched up and it's like he's
very carefully analyzing because
that's an explosive move and i think
wesley's aware of it
i think wesley's aware of this
possibility because white is now in the
position where
he's trying to stabilize and he'll say
if i
set everything right in my position
i'll get my attack going and you won't
go anywhere unless you get
some kind of play on the queen side so
b4 is a thought but man to calculate all
that
you know he could find it with the idea
that he's taking on e4 and hitting the
rook on h1
right that may be your you say i get
material
is it is it worth it you know when
you're attacking and you know that it's
a draw
right my line goes like this and i have
prepared okay
at least i have perpet so i can go into
this line
because in the end i can bail out in
this position he could say you know
that rook is always hanging so let me
see if there's
more munchies in there and if he starts
to find some of these crazy lines with
the rucksack
on before first of all i would be amazed
i would say jeffrey welcome to the 2770
lane
because he is taking steps towards
becoming top 10 in the world
and you see there he's he's trying to
figure it out you can tell he feels like
it's right now is the moment
if he plays b4 guys we're in for
a ride yeah we are we are i
i don't know i mean okay so we've looked
at knight a5b4 like what else would be
in your candidate list here i mean of
course i would look at the forcey move
knight e5 but the problem is after queen
f4 it actually blocks
my attack on the ebon so that's
definitely sub-optimal
would i even look um what else what else
is there like what are your other
candidate moves maybe moving the queen
somewhere
so that i would be looking at if you
were just looking at candidate moves
uh knight a5 obviously my number one
move
another candidate move would be the move
d5 that i would be thinking about if you
play rook takes d5 i
i'm nothing really special i just like
the idea of defending this pawn
and maybe luring your rook to a square
where it's quite
vulnerable the knight and the bishop
will combine um you know it's it's
strange i i
uh he played it i wouldn't he
played b4 amazing
wow and now okay okay all right so this
name
let's concert ourselves so if we if we
don't play
a takes before other moves look bad
because then you just have
the same variation but without
um stacking a whole piece so obviously i
can't take with beat with the knight
because then you just do the same thing
and
have an extra piece and the c pawn looks
looks even really bad even worse because
that
you can just see your king is really
exposed
uh so a takes b looks box as we would
say
forced uh knight takes b4
now here i might chill first of all i
just have to get
you know like whoa my my world just got
rocked by the move b4
here i would just have to say okay okay
okay do
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna take the
knight but do i have a bailout variation
could i play move like
for example rook d4 and somehow scramble
to equalize or
what have you so i just want to make
sure that
you know i'm not just going to go
sailing down that river
where i don't have a paddle um so
knight takes b4 i mean i'm going to take
the knight sure i get that but
is there a refutation to rook d4
other than you're just not sacking
anything and you've exposed my king
that sounds like a very happy camper
wasn't that enough
yeah i loved everything enough and look
at this attack you just get a full
open file and threats everywhere
exactly not not feeling this work you
can't even play
you can't even play rook b4 here that
position you just played you can't even
play rook b4 because the queen before
i like something that we were looking at
earlier because at the end of the day
you traded queens and i wasn't getting
checkmated as white
exactly that's good that's a good thing
right
so knight takes before you gotta move
like b4 and you don't see it and then
somehow and i'm not saying wesley didn't
see it but i
i i don't know i don't know that's a
that's a bomb yeah studied this before
there's a really good chance he hasn't
because it's all
even at the very highest level it's
easier to see ideas for yourself
than it is to see ideas for your
opponent that's just a
human principle whether you're 2700 or
1600 or just started the game it's just
a thing
so um and we weren't we weren't even
sure if jeffrey would see it because
there's so many logical attacking moves
here and that this one is
kind of funny but the reason he finds it
is because of loose pieces this
principle
of the work on h1 that's hanging
and how you combine that against attacks
on the king and it on z1
yeah i love that bishop on e4 that's
covering these two
incredibly important squares in front of
white's king so bishop
takes i'm looking at um a b
knight before knight b4 bishop e4 that's
our our key move now
we played queen here last time you
dropped this
move on me uh on us maurice
rook takes c3 but i must confess rook
takes b4 i must confess that
i actually was frightened over the move
queen a5 i saw a you know
potential of queen a1 and that was
frightening but
is rook before the best engine move
uh i will turn it on and check
v4 queen h3 rook b4 is the number one
move yes
the queen h3 runs into bishop d3 it's a
full scale reputation
uh which is what incredible is that
uh bishop e4 queen h3
rook b4 yeah how did queen a4
bishop queen a5 you played queen a5 not
root beefer
you said is ruby for the best move you
said queen a5
yeah and bishop d3 refutes it bishop d3
just
and we have liftoff a takes b4
knight takes b4 bishop d3 is a
refutation because the king can hide on
c2
and that's that so knight takes on b4
instantly banged down
by the youngster and you've got to look
for moves by the way i saw another move
in your line yes
the line was rook d4 knight c2 king c2
in your variation and
then queen b6 within a
with an additional threat of queen takes
b2 right now exactly
yeah no i i i definitely recorded
discovery check so knight takes b4 on
the board
wesley's going right into the line we
have bishop takes
e4 it's all the way
so not your queen h3 to protecting their
work on h1 and looking at the c8 square
but instead
queen f4 okay so what happened
before what's his idea here no but your
rook is hanging right
your rook is also just i just i i just
want to listen
i just want to say if you take the rook
then
f3 and the bishop's a little bit trapped
and uh but here a bunch
i'm much more worried about my king than
my rook so
rook b4 is the scary move right yeah
rook b4 looks scary because if you play
cb4
now i i like check you and
you're being told you're walking this is
a blunder we're being told this is a
blunder and now queen a5
is crushing for black queen a5
is a huge move that will put him in deep
trouble because now
bishop d3 doesn't work the way it did
before
because you simply take on h1 and now
after
after rook takes h1 queen check on a1
bishop b1
rook e2 is the spicy move
and this is a monster shot wesley so
in deep trouble if the youngster
can dig and look at his eyes look at
jeffrey's eyes staring down the board
right now
he knows he can take the rook he knows
he can sack but if he finds queen a5
wesley is in deep trouble
i think it's funny in one moment the
move queen a5 can be refuted by bishop
d3
just half a play later queen a5 turns
out to be
a huge bomb and he's like whoa
and the difference is as you said
there's a rook e2 landing on the board
let's go through this again
uh what is the refutation again for rook
before because that was the first move
i saw and i was petrified by it yeah i
mean that's a thing
queen a5 looks like a great move to look
at but the first thing you're looking at
is
yeah looks like lost right queen c7
check
and it just lights up queen c bishop
three three and then um then
in that line bla white is just mated
right right um if you want to just at
least show what happens if pawn takes
before i don't think we should do we
show that yet
that queen c7 king d2
queen c2 mate king e3 oh sorry not mate
king e3 and then just retreat the bishop
somewhere and
you're out of you're out of squares
you're
getting dated and he has played rook
takes b4
but maurice you mentioned a move
bishop d3 bishop d3 is his only defense
right now and it does equalize
this wesley will dodge a bullet but i
will say
i overstated the case bish queen a5
was actually playable with bishop d3
and bishop d3 on the board as wesley is
getting out of here
oh he said i want my teeth in my mouth
so i'm just going to go for it
but queen a5 bishop d3
yeah takes on h1
and here don't take this bishop just
play
f3 and close your eyes and hope
everything's okay
this this would bishop g2 would be the
next move
and white can now try to play this
position
right even though he's not in exchange a
full exchange mind you
he does have some nibbles against that
bishop on g2 he could also play h5
and maybe even argue your attack died
for because you stole material
and maybe i have some chances the engine
gives black
the clear edge up one as much as a
hundred senti pawns
but this is a different position all
right i'm gonna turn the engine off
and we can go to this position where
bishop d3 shut down the attack as well
and it looks like jeffrey will come out
of this one okay with just
moving his rook after bishop to d3 but
also
uh wesley survived that storm try to hit
him
what do we do here do we play bishop
takes h1 and then queen takes b4
and um then we move the bishop to f3
that's a forcing line right
bishop h1 queen b4 bishop f3 and who's
better there
bishop f1 bishop h1 queen b4
bishop f3 yeah i mean this looks
dangerous i mean where are you going to
put your rook
you want to put it some passive square i
guess i
well i didn't really have a choice if i
go to d2 i was afraid of
e1 check and so i was
thinking cover the first rank and
maybe try to slide my king over into the
corner and i get it there's not a lot of
material left on the board so like if i
had like more
major another pair of major pieces to
play like rook v8 or
have a fun party on the king side yeah
there's no easy entry point is there
yeah yeah like if i play queen c7 with
the idea of rook v8
um well it's slow it's slow
though yeah white's white stabilizing
this position even a6
might hang in some position and the d6
pawn is a bit
weak so this looks like it's very
survivable wesley
put on his his near 2800 hat
and said let's shut down this
youngster's aspirations
what a sequence of moves however by the
series by jeffrey i mean
that was crazy that was really crazy
high quality game so far
guys yeah for a rapid game amazing it's
like his uh what is that
the cape of you know invulnerability you
know bulletproof cape
he put on that little bishop yeah bishop
d3
nice okay so we've got a real big game
and we're going to stay with
it trust me i just wanted to take a peek
at that
other major game that was going on
between ray robson and ikaru nakamura
and this looks like i mean if
if if we weren't watching the the fight
for first place
i bet you dollars to donuts we would
have
have our eyes peeled on this game
this looks like crazy crazy as well
yes my first impression is like wait
well i guess i should know whose move it
is but it looks
scary for nakamura because rookie 7 is a
big threat i assume it's his move and he
can play like 95 or something
it's true it is his move is his clock is
the one
ticking but knight e5 is going to
walk into maybe rook f6 maybe 28
preparing 95 or something
okay and gift me is one
uh-huh yeah and i'm waiting for 95 so i
can
he did play 95 by the way so he must
have some tactical
idea or maybe just moving the queen to
the defense on g7
i think he's trading rooks and taking on
on c4 though
trading rooks and perhaps taking on c4
pause pause pause because my spidey
sense is tingling here just as soon as
mine
what's going on here
i guess you just changed seven or
you just asked the question what's your
threat
oh that's brave because i know i know
yeah seven square
by the way isn't that the way this
tournament is going i mean
like you know nobody's backing down and
playing defensive moves it's like they
forgot how to play defense
it's all about attack attack you played
queen f8
he played queen f8 queen e7 sorry queen
e7 pinning the rook
sam shanklin from the last from the game
against
against um who was it the youngster
was a wanderlier sam shankly remember he
pinned this rook
i do g7 but this time another pin but
easy to answer now with rook takes f8
and the argument is you have two pawns
two pawns
and a rook for a bishop and a knight but
that knight on e5 is as secure as
an ox can be yeah look at the times
good night four times as much time
we have for nakamura as for ray and by
the way that mirrors the situation
between
our absolute money game between wesley
soh
and jeffrey zhang as
jeffrey has less than four minutes as
he's trying to decide what to do after
wesley's stellar defensive move bishop
to d3
and i got to tell you i was praising
jeffrey for being such a
you know wonderful practical player but
i mean there's no better practical
player than wesley so right i mean this
guy
plays fast and um great psychological
game
this is bad news for jeffrey really bad
news
he's looking for moves here and
he's not finding any body blows but he's
going to go under three minutes
to wesley's 15 plus that's
that's really bad news he's got to take
the work on h1 or he's got to move his
rook on b4
right because rook a4 though is the only
move because you're right so we're
paying for in bishop h1 this is the
crossroads and you can kind of
understand why jeffrey
is thinking here because there's going
to be a lot of trade well not a lot of
trades but significant
trades considering how few pieces are
left on the board and so
it's a critical moment but there might
be future critical moments and he's not
gonna have time to think about it
he's under three minutes now and the
time is ticking down very quickly
he threw out all those blows at his
illustrious opponent
and he has accepted them as wesley and
i'm sorry
i'm seeing a blunder in the future for
jeffrey
i'm seeing a really bad blunder coming
up soon
because you cannot be down i mean
jeffrey's going to be the one
who's going to be attacking and wesley
is going to be the one defending if he
shoot in a lot of variations and and
he's taken on
juan after a long thing got under
two and a half minutes and i'm just
looking at a variation
queen takes b4 and last time i was a
little bit reluctant
after bishop f3 to give up the first
rank
this time i want to just imagine giving
up the first rank
because in this particular case i do
keep an active rook
there is a weakness on d6 there's a
weakness on a6
and with my rook on d2 i'm eyeballing
the spawn and
maybe i'm a happy camper i like white
yeah i'm feeling a little bit more
harmony in white's position
if i have to do it i can go b3 king b2
bishop c2
and frankly the rook isn't bothering me
unless a queen lands on a1
the queen is dominated though the queen
is dominated he can't get in the game
and the back you're gonna you're gonna
have back crank issues yourself
you can't leave on the back you have to
play g6 in order to make
luft but that weakens the f6 square i
like white
exactly what's not to like about white's
position here white has all the
flexibility
in the world with no weaknesses no
attack this is why
this is why jeffrey looked at this for
so long and queen takes b4 on the board
expect bishop f3 brook d2 instantly
played
by wesley and against keeping
white with the advantage here pawns are
at least the a6 pawn
is hanging this is good for white yeah
this looks like uh
bad news better structure better
structure and d5
i like this move because i'm thinking
that
funnily enough this bishop actually is
like you know like floating in air
and the move d5 does secure
uh the e4 square but having said that is
uh
am i right what's over there is this
no what is up with this i mean the
bishop's trapped right
mission before i'm taking it maurice
oh there's bishop before rookie for
queenie for yeah oh yeah
all right i'm i'm missing movies yeah
okay yeah yeah
[Music]
that lifted the comments me too right
you do and then um i guess we have to
play
bishop h5 that's our only one then i
don't want to check i i
then sorry to check
in this position why not just move the
bishop back
and then ask you what you plan to do
yeah it was funny i mean
uh what can i say the bishop h the h5
square was kind of like
hidden i was thinking i was trying to
just trap the bishop and force it to the
e4 square
d5 on the oops excuse me d5 on the board
wesley to play maybe it's time just to
go b3
king b2 put the queen on d4 could i
could i get an answer to why bishop
takes a6's back
of course of course of course uh bishop
takes a6
okay so check
king check i've got bishop d3 that
doesn't bother anybody
where does the queen go where
it can be potent how does this queen get
into the game
it looks dominated queen a8 was my
biggest fear
but with my with my queen on b4 i'm not
worried
right he took it he took the pawn but
the engine said that's not a good move
and h6 was not i didn't expect that one
to
come out of nowhere wow he took the pawn
on asics asking the question in the u.s
h6 is so that
i don't understand h6 what is the point
he just needed he needed
he needs to get his parents again
for example something like that uh
because the problem that he's having
is that anytime he's facing this back
ranked mate
uh he can't get his pieces out so at
some point you've
got to make look for your king he
figured now's the time
uh h6 on the board that's a remarkable
point because queen is so important in
attack
and you're right i don't really have c8
i don't have a8 because you
hit me with queen b7 um i kind of have
c7 but you've got that
situation on lockdown with the pawn and
the queen both defending c3
right so yeah a fascinating point but
the h6 not only makes
look it allows the big gun in okay
so he took but doesn't it asking
whoa he's just he's just ramping up the
volume
i thought is jeffrey he played rook to
e4
i thought six was his idea uh at least i
i understood queen f6 to be the idea so
that you could
play queen takes h6 or snag a bishop
rook e4 instantly played
he wants to take h4 with a queen oh
i mean yes and you i would think you'd
like this a little more yes wild
it's it's crazy uh wow that
that came out of nowhere okay if i'm
white i'm playing h7 check
because i can't play king h7 you have
bishop d3 precisely
so then you have to go king to h8 right
right king f8 not even legal but if it
was
a queen good point and
let me let me threaten to trade queens
with the move
queen f queen b7
threatening to trade queens by the way
he looks like that he played queens no
but there's
a similar idea though yes he's
threatening queen c8 and
also h7 idea still in the air maybe it's
a bigger version of it
maybe a trickier version because queen
c8 check
and queen f5 check could he took on
age four like this with the wrath pieces
don't seem poor i mean
why didn't he play rookie one and queen
h rookie won bishop e4 and queen h4
instead of it was that a blunder i'm
trying to understand
well i'm sure he was trying to make sure
to stop h7
could you go back a second could you go
back a second please rook
e1 king king up rookie want
you played rookie for queen c5 no
rookie four-hour queen c5 rookie queen
c5
rook e1 king c2 bishop e4
check bishop d34 bishop d3 and queen
h4 is this a blunder
blunder no why would this be a blunder
um
or is it bad should i because it's in
this pawn
if i take on d3 you're taking with a
rook
imagine i'm taking on d3
taking with the rook i've got f2 covered
by the way guys let's catch up with the
game because it's like
rookie two check rookie two back up with
the game because then queen e4 so
i think that was a better way to play
but they've traded and gone down to a
simplified end game
where wesley will try to prove that his
b-pawn
has real significance
well this queen c8 that was the move i
was angling for
any time i get the two connected pass
pawn is just gone
it's just over like nothing to discuss
that's just winning
here yeah here the nice thing from
white's point of view
is he's got the tricky move c3 c4 in the
pocket
so to speak because of that nasty pin
so let me start with the move b4 here
and i
think wesley cruises to victory here
because
king b2 and c4 is what's on white's
agenda
king c2 b5 and c4 also
either any combination of those moves
and white
b-pawn is just the most important passer
yeah and it's hard for us to make a pass
pawn you just keep pushing your b-pawn
forward
as he's played before played on the
board
king f8 okay i think this was a really
good move by
jeffrey by the way you've got to make it
as difficult
as possible for your opponent the b pawn
was too strong and
and jeffrey's looking at king e7 king d6
as a possible defense to try to hold on
wow what a game so far guys no matter
what amazing this game
you can't you know feel that our eyes
are riveted right
yeah okay so so so let's just go ahead
so if i go king d2 here how would the
game go i'm assuming king e7 right
and c4 maybe you can squeeze
in rook here h4 yeah you wanna
you wanna avoid that no so maybe you
need to well i i'm
i'm still not 100 sure that your king is
close enough to
this guy i mean these guys are still way
back there
so the b-pawn is the important one right
now this is probably a draw i don't like
this okay
so um well b4 on the board king f8
king b2 looks natural king e7 looks
natural
jeffrey did miss this queen h4 idea
earlier he did he should have could not
have played rook to hh4 you should have
played rookie one check
yeah and take one time pressure thing he
spent so much time deciding between rook
h1 and rook a4
he ran out of time to decide between
queen h4 and rook h4 that's what it is
that's what it's all about
trying to have time to think during the
critical moments
that's cool this is what world champion
magnus carlsen said that the rabbit
chest
is the most difficult time control for
him to master because
when he's playing blitz he's in a rhythm
right you're just in a rhythm when
you're playing classical chess you also
get into that classical chess rhythm
with rapid chess you've got to be able
to juggle both
and from one to the next uh you're
suddenly in a blitz
uh as we see jeffrey now with a minute
and 40 minutes 40 seconds for the rest
of the game
with the increment bonus it's funny that
you say it's the most challenging for
him because he's got the biggest rating
differential
of everybody in the world the most
challenging for him
maybe he means that in like an absolute
sense
yeah like difficult to tackle it
but he's still a relatively um even
even bigger margin of um advantage in
that format than any other
remarkable i mean magnus is
extraordinary
i think i might be wrong about that i
think that used to be true
and now it might not be true but in in
the past he used to have like 100 points
plus i think in rapid i think more
recently
maxine maybe has um you know gotten
corrupted and narrowed that bridged it a
bit
yeah and wesley by the way wesley after
this move king f8
has stopped he simply stopped because
here i i think he's
really giving rook d3
series consideration with the idea of
trying to
force bishop e4 rook to d4 somehow
he's trying to put the bishop
where it's absolutely the most
vulnerable he played king b2
and an unexpected move by jeffrey rook
f5 see seeking to prevent
the move c4 by protecting his bishop
switch over very quickly by the way
just quickly while wesley's thinking so
the game between rey
and hikaru and rey is
hunting hikaru down trying to prove that
his
rook is better than the bishop in the
knight look at this position a b6 pawn
could drop
but is it going to be enough as the
minor pieces will try to concoct some
attacking lines here
but he can take the b-pawn and say i've
got a pawn still or the d-pawn
which one are you going to take and he's
he has taken on
b6 so big results here for us
in terms of the standings if ray can
somehow pull this win off
he's only got 34 seconds left 34.
but ray for choice certainly no question
can't be too accurate now he's got to
play completely on instinct
so yeah this game is critical for the
standings without any question
as we see now wesley's king is on a4
racing up the board wow all right let's
whoops i went to the wrong one racing
you can't you can't go to b5 or a5
because then d4 attack
um spells catastrophe right i guess you
had king a6
well yeah yeah you don't want it yeah
okay but he did play b5
b5 is a private as a prelude to king
a dream for wesley is that somehow by if
by magic he could just
like move his king like a knight put his
king on b6
then put his bishop on c6 then he's
really
got a great position the question is
can't
jeffrey get his king to c7 in the nick
of time
c4 is potentially a problem but
we should note no matter what jeffrey's
thinking about he's got to do it quickly
47 seconds left if it was it were three
minutes each on the clock
i'd have more confidence the engine is
saying white is only slightly better
which suggests that
this game is okay for jeffrey right
but
he has to do it quickly it's only a five
second increment
he began with rook to f4 check that's
not a c4
but there's a rook d4 suddenly here
and whose pawn is more
dangerous good point rook d4 i don't
know if i tried and played
king play e6
and play king and then you play beast
but you do have to worry about
black's pawn i mean i do i do i do i'm
headed straight to b8
that's what i would do you're not making
it you're not making it to b8
it's impossible i'm playing b6 you're
king kia yeah and he didn't play rook d4
he played
king b4 that was a big time moment i'm
not saying he missed an opportunity
i wasn't forced to trade rocks like i
could have played bishop before if i
wanted to
but yeah then we're just going back
so yeah okay now this is this is huge
uh wesley threading bishop takes d5 and
b7
oh boy maybe or just simply bishop
a6 and b7 okay rook c4
kind of a vancoura setup to use the rook
to check
constantly and to just try to take the c
pawn i think also so that you never have
that c4 stuff that
was you know so annoying that's right
okay so rook to he is defending
monstrously one defended like a god and
now the
the next one is defending these
d3 generators c5 check yeah as you're
going back
yeah i have to aha so if you play rook
d3 rook c5 check and you can't nestle up
to a6 because of bishop e2
exactly that's my problem that was
exactly my problem works youtube just
looks so alarmingly passive
might might allow uh
some horribleness with king c5
and look at that wesley shaking his head
he's shaking his head as rook c5 played
and he
realizes he cannot send his king up the
board
which is the most desirable movie
backwards
and a check on c4 and saying send your
king all the way home
all the way what a fine by jeffrey this
looks excellent as a sequence for the
black player
oh it's brilliant because now the rook
guards you from ever playing that
um you know c4 move that yaz has been
pounding the table for
yeah yeah give me a chance give me a
chance wesley still playing for the win
he's played king b3
could have played king a5 repeated the
position
yeah okay because he's still he still
sees that pawn on b6
it's still an idea to play things like
bishop d5 and b7
bishop e4 is what i'm planning to do
attacking the rook
bishop e4 attacks the rook bishop d5
isn't that a
bishop d5 man i thought i was taking a
rook but i guess i'm not
and i'll be 55 seven seconds and he's
playing
seven seconds
now bishop d5 is checked bishop d5
bishop d5
rook d5
can't play king d5 you have to actually
move your king over to c6
oh there it is you're right so we can
just play king c6 there
that's insane that's not the end of the
story guys just a second
takes takes takes
king c6 rook b5 and what's the three on
b7 b7 and you're losing yesterday oh
let's go right you look i take on f2
i take on f2 i'm threatening c6 check
okay i play rook f6 threatening
check wait i could have also checked you
all the way up the board but i don't
think i want to do that
look no no no no i c4 by wesley
c4 c4
defibrillator c5 and somehow somehow the
kid is fighting all the moves because
the engine is saying
correct correct correct correct and yeah
i
seriously can't believe that he found
king c5
brilliant move brilliant move by because
v6 is hanging now and that's the money
pawn
that is the money fund wow wait until we
wait
what happens if bishop takes b5 um
i can't take the pawn right away because
i lose a piece so
i have to take that first still and you
don't have time for b7 because my bishop
talked
we got a check right jack
[Music]
but that allows rook before no no we
can't play check seconds left for
jeffrey three
take the pawn oh god he's playing check
isn't this bishop is bishop's not
hanging what does he find
all right he's going to take the b6 pawn
and it is bl
white's bishop's going to hang on he can
play check he can play rook c4 check no
he could just take bc
b6 yeah yeah because
by the way rook b4 check i think was the
most precise move
and but wait a minute there's a great
six right now isn't there maybe i was
right maybe this
was the move oh my god d6 d6
d6 wins material wait wait he's got it
he's got to take he's got to give up the
exchange he's done he's going to be down
material he's got to take can he draw
this end game
can he draw i think he can draw easily
okay and vod vinnick the the bishop is
has an anchor square ah you play
yes for bishop e4
anchor square oh my goodness
know your bod vinnick everybody but
jeffrey's not sure look at this he's
shaking his head
all he's going to do is play f5 and then
b44 bishop e4
ed it's a draw and wesley knows it why
didn't he play bishop d5
and g4 that looked more secure at what
moment
uh instead of f5 right now oh sorry just
a second
you mean in the game position why didn't
he play bishop
d5 bishop e6 and then g4 very good
fortress-like position as well yeah i
mean
you don't win that at all because you
have to sack your rook for the for the
bishop in order to win
and your king will be out of the way so
it's just
i i agree i think that there's i mean
it's a stylistic thing right
uh for me i like this but i can easily
imagine
other people would with the pawn on f7
and the bishop on e6 and upon the
engine's going crazy right now because
because what about because what about
rook f7 rook takes f5 is threatened uh
no king you win it's a win it's over
it's over rook takes a five and then he
takes g4 and
it's winning wesley is going to win
bishop d5 bishop e6 was more secure
this is over you're just take now just
take on f5
and you're going to get the tempo for
the king and pawn ending wesley is going
to win the game
incredible defense and he and he missed
it at the end to play bishop to e6
and bishop d5 to e6 and g4 but what it
what a heroic
oh my god my name i mean can you say
either of these guys
it was incredible a bad game wait so
what what was the moment bishop e6
you said well okay let's go to the end
of this game because
ray only has 10 seconds left on the
board
menace not even looking at the board
looks very upset what happened
quincy he's
losing his queen he's losing at least a
piece
um because if king d5 there's rook d7
in this position we have right now and
if king e5 brook takes on f7
isn't that just a piece that looks like
a piece rook takes f7 you don't have a
check
in the world it's over ray is going to
pull himself back
up just take on f7 if you don't see
anything else
the guy has no checks oh well okay you
can also check that's even better
because now we get to take on f7 with
jack
i'm with that although i can take my
sheep on and i must be winning somehow
but
well i'll trade queens if i can't find
the mate with my rook
and agree i think that i think the rook
and the
queen will overwhelm oh that's a nice
move by ray that's
that's that finishes that finishes it
that's it yeah now you go rook g7 and
now you're actually
two pawns ahead and with all kinds of
time on the clock to be able to move
and mess around nakamura stunned losing
yet
again in this event wow uh incredible
absolutely incredible that this has
happened to nakamura here comes the king
and time just being added on every
single move
this is resigns they can't be will join
jeffrey at seven
while wesley has gone to eight
with a pointless four-point lead right
and
ray and jeffrey will both be saying
come on ikaru pull yourself together win
that last round game against wesley so
do as a solid wesley man i mean the way
he played that last game
fighting for the win finding all the
right defensive modes
i mean that's that's monstrous wesley
that's the kind of weapon yeah
just trade bishop rook for bishop and
bring your king on f4 and steal the
tempo
that's wait is this the same end game
that wesley had
that's exactly the same position exactly
rook x and this king f4 and then take
the tempo
and that's your simple king and pawn and
that's why you need to know those tran
transitions because we got the same end
game where white has the tempo
to win and nakamura is devastated
but we had alejandra ramirez still
playing let's
bump over to his game oh wait a minute
hold on
alejandro this time we're actually going
to see a
knight win the game because he's got
knight e3 check so the king
is not going to be able to make it to a8
in time
and thanks to knight d2 the
king is going to be blocked out like
uh hold her and there you go
alejandro finally saying
he came he i i
i saw his interview with you uh maurice
and he said
i want to win some games i want some
scalps i want some 2700s
uh well he got a scalp maybe it's not uh
wesley or hikaru but it's a scalp
all right this one's over could we go
back please to show that position
which oh wander is still playing let's
finish let's look at this
wander and uh lanier are playing
and again another very theoretical uh
rook and
you got to know those endings for for
these rapid time controls
you have to know your endings and this
one pawn and the king and bond
we see them again and again exactly
well it was like my my friend uh mike
michael
mike j from frenet michael frenette um
was many many times champion of
washington state and he said to me
he advised me yes sir study your end
games
he said it's like cheating because
you're going to get
end games cheating for an exam so
study your end games everybody king 32
white just doesn't have a way of moving
that rook off of b8
and the king can't go down the board
because it's going to be checked
mercilessly
from behind i mean it could it could
definitely go up the board white king
will make it down the board but when it
arrives it's just going to be checked
out of its mind
well the thing is though maurice if i
can okay
imagine white does get his king to c6
then you're going to give me a check
right and then i'll go to d6
and then you go behind can i go to
e5 and try to clip the spawn or is it
rook b5 time
i think i have answered my own question
there i think that
just rook b5 is sufficient for the draw
linear down to 15 seconds
and a wonder said okay i've
i've got to go for this i've got to go
for this but uh
no this is not just a journal
and there is no i think it looks like
they made a draw oh no yeah
no here you just take and well i mean
you just
fill a door defense you put the king
there's a
okay that sounds good i gotta tell you
guys
i mean i need a rest i made this
this has been heavy on my system all too
much excitement for yeah they're
throwing variations
we're missing moves we're miss calling
squares
we're ghosting every i mean they are
throwing stuff at us
and making it a challenge to figure
things out as we saw the draw go back to
that game though because i
which game the game the money game
wesley
and jeffrey jeffrey had defended just in
herculean style
and he had this position where he played
the wrong
move with the bishop when he had the
sack right here
and bishop d5 is the most obvious move
on the board bishop d5
guard your pawn so when i first saw it i
said
can i play this move because now i'm
playing g4 on the next move
and bishop e6 after that and you can
you can sack your rook eventually you
can get your king in and you can
eventually sack
but the pawns are too far split you can
go do whatever you like
sooner or later i will i will you could
sack on e6 if you like
but the i think you have to make sure
though that the king
like this is clearly a draw i think you
have to make sure
that the king yes is is up the board
not down the board so what you do with
the black king is you stay on c4
c4 c5 all right so let's put let's go
like
let's play king c4
and play game c4 and then king to f4
and play the king c5 you do it any way
you want qc5 king up uh
king's king over and now
at some point you're going to sac
actually i think you need to keep your
king on e5 and play rook
d6 because if you do this my king gets
close so
rook d6 and this position now when you
take actually king d3 king z4 king e2
so i have to stay on c3 not here because
you'll play
king f5 here and win so you have to play
king c3
you have to have your king on c3 so that
you can play king d3
so king c3 now rookie 6 fe 6
king takes and now king d2 or king d3
and now king and that's it
and that's how you show the game you
have to keep your king up board and wait
for his sacrifice
so you can counter and that would have
been his draw
wow uh jen what can i say
set the table for us what's our
standings after nine rounds
wesley so with a big eight points out of
nine just two rounds to go
he looks unstoppable with his
combination of defensive resources with
finding
every chance to win but jeffrey zhang
and ray robson i mean what incredible
performances by both of them today
ray robson coming back from a tough win
against jeffrey
to be lost none other oh sorry a tough
loss
to jeffrey to be none other than carmen
nakamura
and jeffrey i mean he lost that game
guys but against almost anyone else
in the planet he would be destroyed
extraordinary that's amazing
and we are we have with us
alejandro ramirez alle this tournament
has been
tough but you finally knocked a big
shark out
how have you been doing my friend i
missed that job with a nice
background and i can plunder all my
pieces and it doesn't matter
oh the us championship is stressful on
its own but it's rapid
and it's online and i'm out of this
world and honestly guys
things have not clicked i've been
forgetting my prep
i've been missing tactics just every
time i look at a position i'm like how
did i make that move right
it wasn't even in my file or how did i
even come up with such a bad move
but my god i'm glad that i won at least
one game because i was so worried i was
gonna finish with zero
wins indeed it has been a completely
wild ride we've seen you at
like you said wins against certain
players and also the opening issues
what what do you think it is is it out
of form like
a forum how did you prepare for this
event
i've been preparing quite a bit i've
been preparing for over a month
uh when we kind of finally settled on on
the format and when it was going to be
but it doesn't really show right it i
think sometimes just things don't click
i haven't been playing chess at all of
course there have been no events
uh it's a little excuse because all
right you can see that other guys are
doing amazing right you can see
like the top of this tournament is just
unbelievable like what are what are we
watching it's just
great chess too no it's just not they're
getting gifts right
uh in my own behalf i don't know i've
never really liked rapid time controls
and honestly online i'm having trouble
uh looking at the board in a very
serious way so
i don't know i'll have to readjust i
really want to make the championships
again another year
uh but we do what we can and i have to
say that this was
a bit of a disaster but but i'm just
glad to be here and i'm glad that i got
to play with such monsters it's always
it's always a pres
a pleasure right like when wesley got
that
minimal edge against me and just you
know took it all the way
i'm like man this guy is really really
good and it's always fun to play
games like that and i'm a little bit
sorry that i wasted opportunities for
example against lanier and hikar where i
just forgot my prep and i was lost out
of the opening
but still the opportunity to be here for
me is amazing
and i just hope to have a better
showings in future years if i ever make
it again
i just gotta ask you alejandro i mean
there's a lot of people out there in the
audience wishing you really really
much success how do you recover from a
game
like a wonderliang because immediately
after the game you say
i missed something and then the computer
showed you that you missed rookie 7 and
knight g6
which would have made it brilliantly uh
does it just haunt your dreams how do
you recover
honestly it didn't haunt me as it haunts
me a little bit obviously because rookie
7 is so pretty and i'm
only looking for tricks at this point
right but the thing is at that point
when i had 40 seconds my mind just was
just blank
i couldn't think it was something that
happened from the middle game
forward and it it's just honestly like i
just shut down
like i had no time i was trying to see
moves and the board just was not
appearing at all uh like this idea of
knight g6 you would think is always
constantly in a grand master's mind
right
but it just it was never in my mind i
was just barely trying not to blunder my
pieces
much less look for tactics and
i don't know i was just not in the right
state of mind in a rapid game that's
unforgivable and at that point it really
didn't matter which moves i wonder made
i would have lost
and you know luckily for him i was there
because i mean he really did
you know blunder pretty badly in that
one but it's part of chess
so i mean you recover you come back the
next day you know that the tournament's
already kind of bad because you know
zero out of three in one day is
impossible to recover from
but uh yeah you do what you can right
exactly you play this game against
darius by the way just
quickly the last question for you you
played this game against darius you guys
have worked together for years
and did it ended in a draw it looked
like a moment of levity for the two of
you
at the end it was like what just
happened that craziness
you know darius and i go back and forth
and
you know he beats me i beat him but he
usually gets the better of me in
tournaments
uh well he is higher rated and in this
one you know he repeated a wanderer's
line uh he was playing his fashion cop
before and i was so happy to get an
advantage a simple
advantage pair of bishops pressing the
entire game
and at some point i i look at the
position i'm like man i'm lost again how
did this happen
so
so you know the fact that i didn't lose
that game was like at least a sigh of
relief
and honestly like not losing games from
now
on is just like you know what i'll take
it that'd be a bonus
all right we'll get you alejandro get
your relaxation on
and we'll look for you on the other side
come back over to the light
nice cameras i'm blundering my pieces
without repercussions i'll be there soon
guys don't you worry
absolutely take care of it it's rough
you heard him say his mind went
his board he couldn't even see the board
we know that feeling when
things are going south chess moves get
harder and harder
they sure do
sam shanklin the 2018
champion sam it's been a rough ride
tell us what has happened
not what you expected for this
championship
that's me hey yeah sam how's it going
yeah sorry guys just working with the
tech stuff yeah could you repeat the
question sorry i just i missed you at
the beginning
i just said it's been a rough ride it's
been a rough ride not what you expected
from this championship
yeah i mean i knew it was going to be
tougher uh both because it's rapid and
online
both of which i'm not wildly good at i i
anticipate it would be somewhat tougher
but
i didn't and i mean you know being on 50
it's not like i'm getting completely
clobbered but
i just sort of knew that with jeffrey
and ray uh who have played a lot online
and are both very good at rap but i knew
they would be
a bit tougher than normal i never would
have predicted that they were this
absurdly strong and they just seemed so
much better than me this game with ray
for example i played
like he just basically played a perfect
game in online rap but that's something
i've never done over the port classical
uh
it's been tough but i've had some good
moments um i've never been a great rapid
player but i've won some good games too
three wins in a row sam so that you you
got off to a little streak there in the
middle
yeah i mean it was a shame because i had
trouble finding my form in the beginning
and i donated all the points to the guys
who ended up leading the tournament so
really right if i had started slowly but
had lost to like
hikaru in the beginning or something and
still had to play with the leaders later
i would have had a chance to fight but
it
it sort of sucked that i i couldn't find
my form right at the start i was still
getting used to it and honestly that
just played really well and then
i already didn't have a chance basically
as early as round four but then i
i was happy that i managed to put
together some wins
yeah that's true the people who beat you
played really well like wesley's soul
game was
absolutely stunning yeah i mean they're
they played great games
uh i'm just i was sort of blown away by
this i certainly can
don't believe that those guys are if i
mean west was probably a bit stronger
than me ray and jeffrey i certainly
wouldn't think so in classical
over the board but it's really just no
comparison in rapid
online they're they're just playing so
much better and i think
if i'm good enough at classical i feel
like i should be able to fix that if i
prioritize it but
i'm certainly looking forward to uh
classical chess coming back
do you think you need to maybe play a
lot more rapid online just to get your
your game more tuned to that well i
think you know practice makes perfect
and if i did a lot more of it maybe i
would be able to play
closer to the same level i do in regular
chess
but at the same time it also comes down
to priorities uh if this just becomes
chess forever then yeah i mean i really
have to do that but i'm still optimistic
enough to hope that
face-to-face events are coming back and
so even though most events have been
online
for the past several months or i haven't
been able to play face-to-face i'm still
mostly doing
training for classical events preparing
classical openings looking at
complicated uh calculation work where
you can easily spend as much time as you
have for the whole game on a single move
uh but yeah in general i think it's
something i haven't done enough
of uh and it really showed these guys
were just better than me this tournament
well i like you're looking at your
bookcase um sam i
i recognize some kasparov books i think
i noticed judith pogar's trilogy
perhaps i think so yeah i've got a few
of these yeah
uh they were all there i mean i got the
whole quality chess catalog perks of
being a quality chess author but yeah
there are a lot of really great books
there very nice thank you
yeah i mean it's fun looking at people's
bookcases
um final question sam um have you picked
up any tips from chess from our party
mafia games
uh no i haven't unfortunately not uh
i'm still trying to just train normally
and hope that i can um
hope that i can play a bit better next
time but there's still a couple games
left and i
you know look if i finish the tournament
on plus two that's certainly far from
the disaster it's not the plus six you
know winning and fine style that i once
had but
you know i'm still thinking i can play
reasonably well but uh
yeah in general i try not to mix work
and fun if that's what you're driving at
jen
well plus two that would mean winning
both your games tomorrow so in order to
do that you're gonna need to get some
rest good luck tomorrow sam
before i let you before you all let me
go i just want to say i just wanted to
say maurice and yes i've talked to john
a bit i haven't seen you guys in a while
i just want to say it's good to see you
and i hope you all are well
thank you man save me a friend you hope
i'm well too
well yeah but no no
have a good one sound take care sam
yes for the foreseeable future this is
what we're doing guys i mean i miss
seeing you guys in person
that's for sure and that's yes that's
what we have to do but
what you have to do is what you have to
do that's life right you take the
waves that come at you and deal with it
as it is
yep humans are very adaptable aren't
they i mean it's amazing how quick
people
get used to things and start improving
in different areas that they never
thought they would
so but no one more adaptable than wesley
so
on the chessboard is he just seems to
be able to make magic out of any
position even when he's under
a massive pressure and he's got a
outstanding eight out of nine right now
and here he is with us
wesley congratulations on a
great day i gotta say you're a point
ahead but
this last game was a war
for the ages oh thank you yeah i
actually prefer this until queen f3
didn't expect bishop b7
so uh so yeah i thought jeffrey might
repeat the semester because he also
plays many other openings
but the semester is very solid
so uh so yeah i wasn't trying to
be that ambitious in the opening but i
thought this idea looks uh
interesting because i'm regretting his
queen side coming to play
yeah did you anticipate b4 his b4
idea yeah i saw before
but i didn't exactly i could i didn't
have time to calculate everything so i
was just
making my moves fast and then thinking
on my opponent's time
seems like a good idea apparently he had
queen a5 on move 22
yes and black is better
this queen a5 would have been
problematic because you have to give up
the rook on h1 yeah exactly and then
black is just much better so
yeah bishop leader bishop each one yeah
yeah and my king is very unsafe
so apparently i didn't play the best
moves he before move 21 was better
but but he spent he spent a lot of time
here i think he went from he went to 12
minutes or 11 minutes
around this stage so he was way behind
the
entire game that was a big factor
but you must have been very surprised to
see him defend so
well even in that ridiculous time
pressure if
he was coming up with move after move to
save himself
yeah i actually am not surprised because
uh
jeffrey and i were teammates in the
online olympics also we did some
inspiring before and after we're also
teammates in the protest league so i
know that
he always finds this powerful resource
resourceful moves and uh
yeah i probably misplayed around here
somewhere because
apparently this should be a draw
[Music]
so i definitely made a mistake around
move 34
something but even here yeah he's still
drawing
did you see yeah drawing fortress at the
end with the bishop versus the rook
no i didn't actually he should i thought
he didn't need to allow that he had
uh in february b6 he had bishop e4
or bishop g4 bishop chief yeah bishop e4
or bishop g4
and if b6 bishop d7 so that draws quite
cleanly
yeah no chances at all to win but yeah i
was kind of happy that he allowed me
this because i wasn't expecting to get
any winning chances later but here he
has bishop d5
and bishop e6 and g4 isn't this a draw
i don't know probably after knows better
than me
yeah it's it it it it probably is uh
he's got the anchor square on e6 and
uh he holds the pawn but you're right uh
you're you're just happy to get this
opportunity
because as you correctly point out
bishop g4
is a cleaner uh way by jeffrey
at this point he had no time though
to be fair yeah exactly though the
opening was so complex
and uh he spent a lot of time but
wait i'm confused i'm confused by
something did you say here
bishop g4 d6 bishop d7 isn't rook d5
apart
does he have to play a check or
something yeah bishop oh wait
bishop oh wait d6 ah you have to give a
check first on c4
all right because bishop g4 d6 uh
doesn't look right
bishop g4 yes bishop g4 z6
you you can't just play bishop d7 right
away because you have a rook d5 check
thread as well
oh because rook d5 is work b6 work d5 is
made
mm-hmm
that's funny that's a hilarious position
can i play bishop e6 on move 45 or
still bishop uh so so sorry
d uh bishop g4 sorry wesley say it again
please c6
maybe after d6 rook c4 draws because
bishop e6 bishop
bishop e6 bishop d5 something like
wow it's getting
weird again i mean we thought we saw a
lot of insanity earlier but this
it it it keeps going it's amazing what
it is oh yeah
yeah from that black throw but if you
have 10 seconds it's very tricky i'll
say
only five seconds increment it's really
not
very difficult absolutely very very very
difficult
yeah i think well wesley wesley you have
a tremendous score
we're showing it on the screen right now
seven wins and two draws you're plus
seven you won a u.s championship with
plus three
could you have imagined a number like
this
no definitely definitely not everything
is going right in this tournament
getting uh i am trying to squeeze my
games and
some of my opponents are making mistakes
uh
but yes definitely a dream tournament
i'm also getting
the positions i like out of the opening
but it's uh not over yet because i play
very awesome tomorrow
what do you think about your road ahead
what do i think about my game tomorrow
ray and you got it
yeah exactly really i mean okay he
carries out the form and i have white
pieces
but he'll probably try to muddy the
water but
definitely my game against ray is very
crucial he has the white pieces
and he's playing exceptionally well in
this tournament he's
taking all his chances he's playing very
aggressive chess
and he's converting even with
very little time left on the cloud
you you've been olympic teammates last
question because that pairing is so huge
you've been a teammate to the olympia
does that factor in at all here
any any love or just you gotta beat the
guy
uh yeah i i
the problem is we we compete more than
we're teammates
so i definitely like playing in in team
events
but the problem is chess is not a team
sport
unlike soccer or basketball so
so you need to play well in order not to
get
left behind i mean uh i really enjoy
playing online
tournaments like uh online olympiad or
approaches league i think in generally i
do very well in a team event because
i like i like playing for for the team
and also competing for
for my friends for other people but
team events are a rare a rarity
we know it'll be a big game get your
rest get your preparation in and we will
see you tomorrow
as you'll be playing championship what
is it friday
thursday thursday championship thursday
for
your second title get your rest
good luck and we'll see you tomorrow
thank you amazing play wesley
bravo wesley by the way we do have our
closing ceremonies and
props to maurice for knowing what day it
was
i know right i'm serious really two
thumbs up maurice thank you that's a
good rescue
they blur all day
just kidding as of course we have our
composed combined closing ceremony for
all five events tomorrow
and that's going to be thursday october
29th
at 5pm central and guys if there's a
playoff that's going to be like
immediately after the playoffs
right yes and the only way all the
champions
the only way a playoff happens is if ray
knocks wesley in the head tomorrow
tomorrow with with black because yes if
he doesn't
that is wesley will have black if he
doesn't then book brexit's ticket i
think
although naka might want to play for
something
i don't know the way he's playing he's
out of form big time
but it all comes down to round 10.
yes the penultimate round don't miss it
tomorrow
on thursday once again thursday it is
it's championship day as we will crowded
champion wesley
looking fantastic but ray and jeffrey
still with a shot as we've had three
outstanding performances in this
championship but guys
there can only be one crown absolutely
and we're gonna leave you with some
funny
player reactions um here from the 2020
championships is sometimes on the camera
away from their opponent they give even
more emotion
than they would over the board so we'll
leave you with that and see you tomorrow
so
you